what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I have a
special guest on the channel welcome
Hafiz what up this is gonna be fun I'm
honestly like I said I definitely did
land from a flight couple hours ago but
I'm very very excited and like I told
you I don't like to talk before an
episode okay I feel like you ruined the
best content so I wasn't trying to be
saying obviously I was just trying to
say the good stuff when the cameras go
on got it guys before we start don't
forget to like the video and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos also guys
we are introducing four membership tiers
so the first tier you get to be a part
of the live chat second tier um you get
to be a part of the Discord and behind
the scenes Vlogs third tier you get to
be you get to connect with me on social
media and fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month um
so I've helped people grow on social
media so you guys should sign up for
that
like I did with you a couple years ago
yes yes you did so it's really
interesting because I meet a lot of
people and I have a lot of sessions and
but I'm really excited about your
journey and learning about it because
initially you asked me did I watch your
channel I'm not gonna lie to you I don't
I gotta give it 100 but I know of your
channel right and then you made a
reference that a couple years ago you
signed up for a session with me we
talked about some of the things going on
with your your YouTube channel and your
goals and your dreams so it's
interesting because I think it's like
what two three years later yeah I think
it's like two years ago yeah two years
yeah about 2020 yeah around that period
of time so it's I think it's really
interesting to see where you've grown
how what you believe and how does that
flesh out into the world today yeah um
yeah because at the time you guys were
one of the only like reasonably priced
like consultations so I was so I was
like I gotta sign up for that
back in those days so
um to start could you tell them a little
bit about your channel cool yeah so my
name is Hafiz I started a YouTube
channel with four four of my good
friends called the roommates back in
2016.
um and then eventually the roommates has
grown and evolved in many different
seasons of life but basically what we
said the roommates was was it was a
place where the everyday man can come to
improve his life so we interviewed some
of the best and brightest individuals
such as Jordan Peterson Gary Vee Patrick
Davis Jose Zuniga I'm Jonathan height
you know and so on came on the show and
the whole goal was to be able to have
these great conversations for the
purpose of building up men as that
continued I would also do live streams
but then I stopped doing live streams
and then eventually I would do
occasional individual videos so we did
that for about six seven years and now
I'm transitioning to a lot more things
that I'm more excited about and um and
yeah so that's the elevator pitch about
me and what I did like what you're more
excited it about well I'm more excited
about the um the standard the
organization that we created and the
standard is an exclusive community of
high performing men committed to helping
one another unlock their full potential
physically mostly spiritually and
financially and through the content of
digital cities so really excited about
this this new thing that me and my
business partner are building so my guy
Joseph Hines and just how it's going to
change the world because I think level
one is content but I think level two is
actual in-person transformation and
that's what we're excited about in this
next season of life so uh my first
question go ahead would you consider
yourself red pill never in a million
never why in a million years why
um I think to me first and foremost I
think I don't subscribe to any man-made
ideology okay because I think a lot of
these ideologies put you in a box
um so I do subscribe to religion and
people can argue with us man-made or not
um that's gonna be great conversation
great debate you get a guy like Sam
Harris and Jordan Peterson had a great
debate about that um but in regards to
man-made ideologies I don't really
subscribe to them as much and I don't
like to identify myself with something
that somebody else has conjured up with
their own personal opinion and so I
think in regards to the red pill is a
very interesting space a lot of
interesting characters there and I think
the the biggest challenge to me is the
the the phrase that they use is that
we're all we're doing is trying to share
the truth about fill in the blank right
and to me it's very very arrogant as a
human being to say I myself am the
orator of the truth I know the truth my
studies are accurate studies my ideas
and accurate ideas I am the only
individual who knows these things and so
to me that ideology seems very cult-like
in my opinion
um if you believe in them they give you
uh praise words like oh yo you're red
pilled you're an alpha male right and if
you disagree with them to give you the
curse words right you are blue pill you
are a Beta male right are you talking
about like the comment section I'm just
talking about this the idea of the
philosophy right okay so the people who
ascribe to the world view are red pill
individuals right their minds have been
opened up to the truth right and people
disagree with their ideas are considered
blue pill right you have rejected the
truth I.E The Matrix right the guy in
The Matrix he said I want to go back in
the machine even though I know it I want
to go back in the machine so to me that
seems very cult to like in regards to
the ideology and so there's a lot of
different reasons why I don't subscribe
to it but those are the few things I
just I just cannot hold myself to an
ideology that a certain individual or
individuals are communicating without
understanding the feelings of those
ideas yeah because they would say it's a
praxeology not an ideology yeah it's
very easy to use words like that but
then then you break down what does that
mean yeah so my question to you is like
what specifically do you disagree with
great question so when people say things
like okay we're not an ideology we're a
practicality right you have to ask
yourself are you teaching any ideas like
is there any principles that your belief
system is teaching because every human
being's belief system teaches teaches
and ideas right and so for me when I see
that there are certain ideas and
premises that are being taught therefore
you cannot simply say we are we are not
an ideology there is no ideals that
represent the things that we believe and
so an example of what are some of the
things to disagree with I think I
primarily disagree with a lot of times
the descriptions of marriage okay and
just how they analyze and describe
marriage in today's world I think I just
I disagree with the analysis of a male
female nature I think if you were to
read a book like the solution of Desire
by Dr David Buss he's a worldly and
expert on human evolutionary psychology
in regards to mating and he's fantastic
bus school psychology is amazing and you
actually read a person who's like a
world-renowned expert on this topic and
you hear about all the nuance and I love
Dr Buss because Dr Buss understands the
nuance and the cross-cultural studies
and so much data and you were to read
some of the more red pill
um you know Doctrine doctrinal books
you'll be like wow like it's you it's
literally like reading Dr Seuss and
reading something like Hamlet it's like
it's like night and day difference and
so to me I think I I I acknowledge that
a lot of their ideas are truthful like
any ideology right or whatever the heck
word they're using nowadays to convince
people that's not an ideology yes those
things are there's truthfulness in it
but there's a whole lot of lies and a
whole lot of information that is not
statistically accurate and that's why
I've always recommended people to to
read books like the evolution of design
by Dr David Buss and then simply then
read whatever red pill literature that
you want and juxtapose those two ideas
and be and you'd be extremely astonished
to the differences well it's just
because everything you're saying is very
broad yeah so you even said like their
teachings on marriage because like from
my my understanding of red pill is that
they're they're not anti-marriage or
pro-marriage they're anti-marriage as it
is today and the way the laws are today
and do you disagree with that so I'm
gonna give you an example okay and I'm
excited because I'm really excited about
the way you the way you're processing
this yeah so let's go into mayor so
here's a here's a fundamental challenge
okay so red pill is very broad okay very
broad right really I don't I don't think
so actually you don't think so no so do
you do you think a person like alpha
male strategies teaches the same exact
ideas as coach Greg Adams
um I know more about alpha male
strategies than coach Greg Adams I
haven't watched a lot of Coach Greg okay
uh AMS he's like the [ __ ] these hoes to
sleep yeah but he's a vault that's old
school I don't know I just if a guy
tells me he watches AMS I'm like I got
it on yeah but but even to that point
right so you're like I gotta run yeah
yeah so so there's there's a lot of
there's then there's you know there's
individuals like Steph is Cole I'm not
sure if Steph is Cole still called
himself red pill but he had to step his
cold guys right a lot a lot different
than coach red pill okay a lot different
um okay so so what I'm what I'm what I'm
articulating is that that within the red
pill umbrella yeah there's a diversity
of individuals yeah this far right this
and there's guys a little bit more
balance so what usually happens when
we're having this conversation which we
require so much nuance and I'm glad
we're able to dive into it is that when
you're describing the red pill what
people want to do is one of two things
you either want to steal men them or you
want to straw man them the argument that
you're probably feeling like and some
people may feel like is that straw man
them right you pick the worst ideas of
the red red pill the worst content
creators and then you define the red
pill as that but then on the flip side
is a steel man where you find some of
their best brightest ideas ignore all
the negativity nonsense ideas and then
Define that as a red pill no I mean to
me it's like there's a base set of ideas
and people have different ideas of what
to do with who defines a base set of
ideas um I would say that I think that's
mostly who's defines the base I would
say Rolo tomasi I think he seems to be
like leading that like today but before
it seems like it was Patrice O'Neill
possibly Patrice O'Neal was was no I I
think a lot of like
um it seems like a lot of ideas derived
from him but it seems like it it goes
around Rolo tomasi that's what it seems
like so the interesting part of the
conversation going back to the red pill
conversation yeah because I know you
want to talk about this is that there is
no single Source there's no doctrinal
Source there's a lot of individuals
who's written their books and shared
their ideas as red pill and depending on
where what school of thought you're in a
lot of individuals will say well that's
not red pill for me he's not red pill
for me maybe in your world he's red pill
for you and some people red pill for
them might be coach Burgett be red
people for them might be fresh to fit
people wear pill for that might be AMS
dude right people for there might be
coach red pill from people right people
for them they all seem to say the same
idea well yes yes it's like so I'm just
like if we're gonna say they're
different like what what is different
okay so in regards to each individual I
can't get into nuances of each
individual so there are some individuals
who are when it comes to marriage are
explicitly marriage I think the whole
institution of marriage in the western
world is done it's over it doesn't work
it's a failed system XY I agree X Y and
Z cool so so that's why that's why red
pill aligns to you because those
emotional sentiments are rock with you
so then there's other emotional it's
because of the legal the way it is
legally a hundred percent so those legal
sentiments yeah rock with children and
we can get into it okay how does those
things fleshed out but then on the flip
side which you have other individuals
who say well in actuality well I I do
believe that in the sanity and beauty of
marriage and if you're going to do
marriage outside of the state I'm all
for it right so yeah some people is like
even with or without the state
institution is broken women are broken
Society is broken doesn't even matter
and some people are like well well
outside of the state yeah
it seems like their prescriptions are
are different but their description is
the same yeah typically so like they'll
say these are the flaws in women these
are the flaws in in marriage but like
they have different prescriptions so
some people will still go through with
it with a prenup and other people will
say screw it all together and so so
prescribing a behavior yeah is telling
people what to do and telling people
what to do also creates a form of an
ideology so if I say I have 10 rules did
I believe men should follow and then say
I have no ideology that doesn't make any
sense so to me an ideology isn't a bad
thing I have an ideology you have an
ideology every human has an ideology so
my biggest argument is not that the
ideology is bad but don't lie and see
that you don't have an ideology when we
all have an ideology so and so in
regards to the original question about
the red pill I believe a lot of the a
lot of what they say is half truths and
like I said for example if you really
analyze human and a male nature and
female nature there's a lot of really
dark and disturbing things about female
nature when you when you can get to the
rawness of it right yeah yeah and if
you're an individual and you're and
you're simply communicating those raw
dark truths about what it was true it
could be very simple simple to realize
that wow man these are really really bad
things I'll give you an example felons
have 30 more children than non-felons I
love it yeah so I don't I don't so you
just threw out a number yeah I've never
heard that you yeah you have nothing to
back it up so another example is I'm
sorry we got we got to stop there what
happens in this community what happens
with with the people who have the school
of thought they'll throw out numbers
where did that where did that stat come
from where did it come from where did it
come from off the top of my head I don't
know but it's easy to Google I know like
if you Google it it's like at the top
it's easy to Google right but the
reality of the matter is when people are
sharing their statistics and numbers a
lot of times they don't know they can't
even tell you the primary source so
because it's like off the top of your
head you're not gonna know like 100
right now why should I believe you why
should I believe you yeah okay but if
I'm saying if I got you the stat I could
look it up now I know you could look
yeah you could take your time you can
pause everything you can look it up but
my point is that a lot of times in this
community they'll throw statistics and
data at you you not you don't have
you're not privy to assisting data yeah
some of it is true some of it is false
right that can go into some of the
truths and false as well and so because
you're not able to Simply look things up
you're in a conversation where you're
like okay I'm gonna give this person the
benefit of Doubt but but if the data is
simply skewed by sheer numbers it can
totally
um this um this spell whether this
person's communicating the truth or not
yeah but it's easy to just like Google
it I know but what I'm saying is yeah
listen carefully if you and I are having
a podcast conversation and you have 15
data points that justify your worldview
but you don't know the source you know
the primary secondary source we could
stop this episode and every time you
pull up numbers I could we could look at
you can look them up you can pull them
up you can show it to me but that's
going to take too long so usually in
conversations like this they don't
you're not able to do so so therefore
what you're forced to do in these
conversations is whenever someone gives
you a statistic that individuals call to
believe it and I've seen that happen
myself because I'm a data person as well
you've consumed my content so you know
some of it I'm a dead person myself so
when I share data there's times where I
was like oh well that number was wrong
but because we're in the middle of a
conversation people simply believe me
yeah and so to me which is fine then you
just update it I know but but in the
midst of the conversation when we're
having these conversations and when
we're sharing all these data a lot of
people will spew data and numbers
it can be truly false I understand
sometimes misinformation happens 100 and
it's not perfect I'm not saying you're
trying to deceive me yeah but what I'm
saying is that there has to be a level
of accountability when we're saying this
is the truth so for one of the things
that I've been improving on in regards
to my speeches that if I share a number
if I really don't know the primary
source or I'm not willing to pull it up
immediately right I'll say well you know
I think think this is the number or I'm
not sure this is a number but what
happens is when you say 110 this is true
the divorce rate in America is 50 it is
true and then you share these explicit
narratives okay and then when you simply
analyze it and break them down you
realize that's not the case yeah but
then then you switch it but I don't
think it's wrong to just say a number
there's nothing wrong and then and then
and then I look it up and it's right
like I've looked that up before that's
not what I I think you're getting lost
you're getting lost in the specific
point I'm talking about the meta Point
The Meta point is that when people are
communicating statistics the audience
has I as totally depended upon the
orator and and if that person says I am
the bearer of the truth a lot of times
in the midst of a conversation a lot of
people communicate numbers that may or
may not be true yeah so my biggest thing
is that when a lot of these individuals
are communicating numbers I'm the kind
of person where I'm like hey let's stop
let's analyze them and let's see whether
they're true or not is there a common
talking point that isn't true that
you're thinking of I I think one of the
biggest conversations that is not
discussed is how marriage is has changed
from the 90s till today okay if you if
you if you look up the marriage the
divorce rates divorce rates have been
decreasing from the 1990s until today a
lot of different studies and a lot of
different analyzations
a lot of different so are you listening
are you trying to talk I'm listening I'm
curious I'm listening because you kind
of seem like you just you're waiting for
me to stop talking so you can say
something no I'm listening God are you
sure yeah I'm listening go ahead okay
so in regards to the divorce numbers a
lot of the divorce numbers that are
communicated today they're not all those
are a lot of all previous numbers and
when you're factor into the trends that
are leading to the lowering a divorce
rates as well as all the different
cross-cultural analysis of divorces
there's a lot that can be learned about
divorces so in regards to the Western
World a lot of the divorce is having
issues they're 100 right but we have to
communicate well here's the reality the
divorce rate has been going down and why
has divorce rate been going down and the
reason why the divorce rate's going down
is because we've learned a lot of
different things about marriage about
divorce about why the divorce rate
Skyrocket initially in 1970s begin with
and so there's a lot of when you hear a
number statistics are great under the
broad scope of a conversation but when
you're really trying to dive deeper into
what's going on today Society statistics
tell you a story right so once you
understand the story behind the number
then you can understand why the number
is practical so in my question is so
when so one of the biggest things that
we've worked on is that if we're going
to give a number we want to also tell
the story behind a number and how is
that beneficial to improving the lives
of people today and so to me that's one
of my different different points of view
is that if you're simply holding on to
any world view and the World Views
communicating certain things that may or
not be true or may not be paying the
whole picture is this for the purpose of
benefiting Society or is it for the
purpose of a perpetuating a narrative
wouldn't you say that the divorce rate's
going down because people aren't getting
married as much so think about it right
this let's talk about divorce rate is by
percentage so let's do some numbers
because you're gonna seem like a very
analytical girl logical we're going to
talk about some numbers thank you so if
the system of marriage is broken right
and a thousand people get married oh I
see the rate would still be I see okay
so let's do it for the people right
remember the the red pill argument is
the system is broken so that means
anyone who engages in this institution
whether or not you do it it's broken
it's not gonna work it's going to lead
to a 50 divorce rate so if a thousand
people get get married therefore it
should be 50 divorce rate but then if
900 people get divorced and 10 years
later instead of the thousand ten years
ago and now 900 people get married and
that divorce rate is 40 not 50 where was
before the question I must be asked is
these 100 people why did that number
change if the system was broken and
therefore whether you where there's a
thousand nine hundred 800 1200 1100 it
should be the same thing but if the
number went down but then the divorce
rate decreased by a percentage why did
it go down who was not getting married
and how would it contributing to the
increase of divorce rates in the past
and that's why I said the numbers will
tell you a story and if you don't know
the full story you don't know how the
number is relevant to lots of everyday
people and that's what I'm passionate
about like you like I want to keep on
saying it a lot of the red pill
arguments are true a lot of them are
true mixed with a whole lot of lies and
and they and we have to be honest there
is an ideological bank and there is a
for-profit bent for the ideologies but
if we're simply going to stop there and
not do a deep dive and analyzing the
study if we don't sit down and analyze
every single statistic number and
juxtaposed with the leading experts in
the world who are also studying these
things we don't have a full complete
message to share to men and women for
the benefit of society because to me if
we're genuinely saying that the red pill
message is the truth if it is in the did
the truth or attempt to convey the truth
the truth should only make Society
better it should only make men better it
should only make women better it should
only create a better world for us and so
to me when I see an ideology when I see
a practicality whatever the heck they're
calling you nowadays well I see a
worldview and I'm looking at it I'm
analyzing it and I'm understanding it
and I'm seeing all people who are
leaders in it and I've seen the
inconsistencies in what they saying what
they do I'm saying that there's a deeper
conversation with the numbers and a
deeper conversation with this type of
information that is not being discussed
and I'm glad we're doing it right now
um to me it's like if it goes from 50 to
40 percent who cares that's that's right
don't do that don't do that though let
me go ahead because to me people aren't
getting together they looked at the they
get it like getting married right is
lower than it's ever been so so it's
like like to me it's just like men are
getting a bad deal today and and they're
and they're signing a contract where
women are paid to leave and take the
kids and and to me that's just
especially in the UK like I live in
London like like girls like their child
supports literally depended on how much
you have the kids so you're literally
paid to take the kids away okay so like
to me it's just like a bad deal and even
even if you sign a contract and it's a
40 versus 50 that's still not great you
first and foremost let's not be let's
not be deceptive right okay you can not
I'm not if you understand statistics you
cannot say a 10 decrease in the
likelihood of something happening isn't
a big deal if there was a drug or if
there was a disease and we said you know
this disease has a 50 percent let me
finish let me finish you told me I have
to cut you off I can cut you off okay
because I understand what you're trying
to do right now I was under the
impression of this was to be a certain
kind of conversation but I'm getting
what you're doing right now so if you
want to make the conversation the way
you want to make this conversation it's
no problem so like I was saying the way
I want to make the colors like I was
saying like I was saying if there was a
disease and a disease had a 50
um fatality rate and all of a sudden 10
years later even if the the people the
amount of people with the disease went
down by two percent three percent four
percent whatever number you want to give
but then all of a sudden that disease
has a 40 fatality rate the fatality rate
went down 10 or we ask ourselves yo how
did that happen no one says oh 50 40 no
big deal so everything's the same thing
no you're gonna be like wow it's still
high then we would like it to be but
it's a lot better than the way it was
before so what can we learn from that
what can we improve on that how can we
make that better and so to me going back
to the ideology my biggest thing is I'm
all about how can we make the world a
better place and simply and simply
saying simply saying that 50 40 that
there's no big difference it's it's
deceptful and deceitful it is not
communicating what's really going on and
so I think it's really cool and it's I I
kind of now a lot of things are making
more sense but if we're going to have a
real conversation about men and women in
today's society and married in today's
society you we have to get into specific
details every single point of the
conversation and understand the Nuance
to each issue so if you want to get into
men getting a bad deal in marriage we
can talk about that specific issue but I
think sometimes it's very easy to be
able to say in our Echo Chambers in our
silos and share these ideas without
having them flesh out that somebody can
give us some pushback but I just think
like you're missing the point like the
point is that the laws don't favor men
today like the point is is it 50 or 40
that's not the point the point is that
like right now it's a contract that
women are paid to leave and so if if
that's the way the laws are set up I
understand why men are walking away like
I understand why they wouldn't push
marriage so here's the deal so let's
let's play your game I love to play your
game I'm not trying to like it's not I'm
sorry okay I'm playing I'm having fun
but whether you're content created we're
having fun come on are we good yeah okay
games is a word guys we're having fun
content we have like that people here
we're having a good time yeah don't take
anything yeah sometimes the peppers
might be too spicy we're just having no
I know I know God so let's play your
game okay let's say the system is all
the way effed up yeah men are getting
screwed left and right what do we do now
um I think you changed the laws like I
honestly actually I'd like to
like to change the laws I love what you
just said yeah I love what you just said
my question to you you're very smart
when we said we should change a loss
yeah how many people are getting into
law how many people are doing content to
be able to change the laws or versus how
many people are doing content simply
complaining about the laws in your
personal opinion all feelings no facts
shout out to Andrew Schultz what percent
of people are actually trying to change
the laws versus people complaining about
the laws all feelings no facts
I know
um either I don't I've met a lot of
diverse they actually have a really have
you ever talked to that community at all
yeah of course I've seen the right
documentary no not even that like they
have whole groups I don't know like
that's that's my you couldn't take
you're a smart woman you have no
educated guess in the world
um I don't think you're gonna like my
answer no no no no no no I know I know I
know I feel like I feel like there
really aren't that many content creators
in the red pill space like I think it's
it's a generally small space on YouTube
so if I had to guess there's probably
more lawyers trying to change the laws
okay so like lawyers that like defend
men and that sort of thing I love it I
love it there's more lawyers yeah my
biggest thing is let's say the laws are
broken I'm about Solutions yeah so what
I'm saying is if you truly believe if
you're like man the system is broken
then the system got broken because
somebody broke it so you're saying that
before the system was working uh-huh is
that safe to say was the system working
before
um before yeah but I'd say before no
fault divorce it was more fair okay it
was more fair so yeah so the system so
in
was the system working yes more it was
more fair before I would say okay so she
said it was it was working before before
it was more fair was it working if it's
broken now it must have been working
before yeah it's it was it was always
broken it would seem like that yes I'm
asking you the right question was it
broke if you're telling me right now
it's broken that's what else is your
words you said the system is broken
right now so therefore if the toy was
broken today does that mean the toy was
was not broken yesterday
um well because because what I'm
thinking is there's like multiple points
that I would pinpoint that started to
like cause the decline of relationships
in the west so it's like you could say
no fault divorce but like then I would I
would also argue that birth control
contributed I would argue like that the
beginning of feminism because I don't
believe in like first wave second wave
Third Way like I think there's multiple
things but I would say before it was
more fair does that make sense okay so
let's let's we'll stay in your lane yeah
I love what you brought up because no
fault divorce in 1970s changed
everything yeah I keep on forgetting the
name of the birth girl is the envoided
and voided 1950s forgot the name of the
first birth control 1950s it changed the
whole entire game right but you
primarily said the the system today is
broken to not benefit men yeah right yes
and so if so my argument is that if you
had a community of guys who are
investing all their money all their
energy we're getting into law we're
we're supporting these people we're
putting these people on our platform if
and we're putting these Champions who
are going to go into Congress and gonna
go into the local places that's a good
idea you should you should do that no
let's stop let's stop right here yeah
you said it was a good idea right yeah
why aren't the why why aren't those
people doing it because because you guys
you're the one who told me they believe
the system is broken that's what you
told me yeah so therefore if they
believe it's broken why are they not
doing everything in their power to fix
the system well I think from their point
of view it's like it's more powerful for
men to walk away because like women need
an incentive for the laws to change okay
so so if men if men walk away from
relationships I mean I I could talk
think of like 10 girls off the top of my
head that are mad because they won't get
a ring okay you know so here's here is
the reality yeah do you really believe
do you like I'm talking about Solutions
here yeah so you're saying the better
solution is for men to walk away from
relationships that's a better solution
for society no no that's not my point of
view I said I think that's a lot of
their points did you know red pill more
than I do you know I'm saying I'm saying
that's their point of view who's there
who's there um I would say that's like
the mgtow group okay
so do you believe it's a good solution
um I believe do I believe that's a good
solution it could be I don't know I
don't I'm not claiming I have all the
answers of course
I have a couple Solutions so I have a
couple ideas yeah
tell you the first idea I have I'm going
to start a wife school I love it yeah so
we're going to turn 304s into wives
That's first that's my first idea yeah
we can we stop right there okay do you
want to go through all the ideas you you
asked me I'll tell you I want to talk
about that one don't forget that one I
want to talk to you about that yeah yeah
I got you I gotta keep on going I got
you we're having fun guys my second idea
my second idea is um I'd like to run for
an office someday because I feel like
for in order the laws to change for men
women have to do it so and if this is
Pro's World I'd get rid of birth control
I'd ban it but that'll never happen a
lot of men won't like that a lot of them
that's my guy right here you say hell or
not you double get rid of that baby yeah
yeah and this is if this is Pearl's
world I'm bam birth control I think that
was the root of all evil and and I'd
actually go further I'd go further go
ahead
say it I I don't know I don't think
women should know I don't think women
should vote Lord Jesus keep on going
yeah no women you can't vote no birth
control keep it going because it's
always freedom without responsibility
and so like the reasons should not be
well I'll tell you why though I'll tell
you why because there's freedom without
responsibility and before women like the
the like I believe in consequences for
your decision so the men know if they
vote someone batshit crazy into Power
you guys get drafted we don't women
decide elections where 55 of the
population I think if we want to vote
equally draft us you don't want equality
and personally I don't want to get
drafted so I'll be in the kitchen she
said women no voting let's go I want
more solutions keep it going yeah yeah
this is this is my world that'll never
happen though I love this
yeah that's it that's all I got okay so
so you wanted to start with wife School
let's start with wife school man we've
we've gotten so we've gotten so deep
deep in the conversation I'm really
excited I hope you have a lot of time
today because I really wanted I want to
dive into everything that you want to go
to yeah here is I'm be honest with you
here is my my only criticism of female
content creators such as yourself okay
if I'm being 100 honest with you I
wouldn't want to ever say anything
behind your background which I won't say
to your face I feel like you guys are
pandering I feel like you guys are
pandering to a certain community of men
who freaking like it's like it's it's
PornHub only fans red pill female
content creators are all that that guess
oh wow that gets them going that gets
them excited right so so I promise
really and the same only thing no no no
no no no no no no no no
yeah wow you can't compete with them I'm
sorry can't compete with them okay
so the only the only family the PornHub
is number one like I'm like one to like
yes and then and then where they're the
only fans depending what she's doing her
only fans it could it can go for
anywhere from 9.5 to 8. okay
so then we'll say the men love your
content so much it'll probably be about
seven a seven yeah okay okay so you
think you said pandering so you think I
don't actually believe any of this no no
no no no no no no because that's what I
hear a panda I look that up because
people say that a lot and it basically
means you just say things because you
don't believe it and you just want the
so if if I want to clarify I said I aha
if if I if I said because I don't
memory's a bad recollection yeah if I
said you are pandering I was wrong okay
I feel like at times content create I
didn't say you okay content creators
like those yeah Pander well there's only
a couple in the space in the red pill
space that are women okay so it's not
about it's not about red pill though
yeah no okay okay so so to me let me
give an example Let me Give an example
okay I genuinely believe that there is a
lot of nuance to your ideas I generally
do not believe you share all your Nuance
online I genuinely believe you are
extremely smart content creator I
genuinely believe you understand what
gets clicks views X Y and Z I genuinely
believe that you're an individual who's
very calculating what you say and what
you do so therefore I was coached by you
listen
that's why that's why it breaks my heart
it breaks my it breaks your heart it
really does I'm not gonna lie to you why
because first you first we had an a
session you weren't coached by me I know
yeah I can't put my stamp on that I'm
kidding I can't put my stamp on that
yeah we're having fun we're just having
fun all right so so my my belief is that
deep down inside I feel like you're a
woman how in the world do you believe
everything a man believes you should
have nuanced positions that's the beauty
of the masculine feminine there's
similarities and there's differences so
when I hear a logical woman I definitely
expect to hear her to communicate things
that the logical male and female
understands but I also expect because
she's a feminine individual and you
believe men and women are different so
therefore if men and women are different
and both of them are communicating their
ideas there's going to be differences
and nuances to their ideas and so
therefore whenever I see not saying you
because remember I told you this I don't
watch a lot about this I don't know it
but when I ever I see those those Pro
male female content creators and I see
like they always have the same male
talking points and there's no uniquely
feminine talking points that men will
agree with but she stands in that
because she is a woman and her ideas are
different sometimes I wonder is this
person fully communicating how they feel
or are they at times pandering because
they understand that by communicating
this way to this audience I'm able to do
better not saying you're doing so I want
you to get mad at me I don't know your
attention
I'm just communicating so when you
brought up the you want to respond to
that yeah I was leading to the white
school point out of the white school
yeah I was just gonna say that I think
it's more having like a father presence
in our lives most of us
um what do you mean what about my mom
you have a motherly presence as well
yeah shout out Jen you calling your mom
by your first name what are you doing
girl yeah
that's a white girl stuff boy called
Mama
no no I mean it's like um I don't know
it's funny because I would say naturally
if I take a personality test that says
I'm very left it says I'm very liberal
so a lot of people think I'm more like
left when they first meet me but like my
dad was just always there to like dispel
everything he doesn't believe in the
voting thing though he thinks I took
that too far shout out pop and I'm not
picking on you yeah let me because you
made up you made the wife School uh-huh
I truly believe women like you this is
why I wanted to talk to you I wanted to
say this to you personally I didn't want
to do dog care I want to say to you
personally because things make great
content women like you have the power to
change everything you made a point in
this you said you believe women can make
a change I truly believe you're you're
so correct women such as yourself such
as yourself wield so much power to make
a true lasting change in this Society
women such as yourself have a so much
power and ability to make a true lasting
change in this world yeah I agree and so
to me my biggest thing is that I want
women such as yourself living out your
full potential and your full skill sets
to be able to truly transform the world
and so to me when you made the wife's
School reference I was like man this I
wanted I'm glad you went there yeah
because the first reason it was are you
married no you so that's why I need wife
school that's what I'm putting it
together no no no no no no no no no no I
can let me look yeah I if you really
want to help women yeah I can tell you
exactly what to do that will be able to
help women here's the reality when it
comes to male content this is not
important they actually think this is a
sign of weakness but this is not
important they don't give a dang if
you're married or not men don't care all
men care is can you have sex can you get
laid if you are a man and you can show
and prove to people that you can have
sex other women other men will respect
you am I making the rules that is what
happens in male contest so male content
creators don't have to be married for
other men to respect them if they show
some receipt to show girls on guys so
girls on parties and show whatever it
may be other guys will respect them and
listen to them because that is the
litmus test for success and men not my
rules is what's going on in today's
world women is different women respect
this women listen to this when you're
able to be like yo you women you can
either be like this like me or be like
this first yeah when you're able to do
stuff like that you're not familiar with
my content I don't really give advice
but okay I know but you said why school
yeah but it's not tough on me huh it's
not tough on me who's gonna build the
wife school yeah I'll put let's just see
if you give let me give the elevator go
ahead please critique the idea please so
that's what I was thinking I was like I
was like oh you know what we should do
we should bring in like wives from
around the world that actually are
married and are actually in those
positions and you could like go through
different classes for like how to dress
like a wife how to cook like a wife how
to clean like like all the things that
like wives have and I was that's what I
was thinking I was like well I can't
teach it I'm not a wife and I was like
but I'm like really good at bringing
people together and I wouldn't I
wouldn't ask someone to do something
that I'm not I'm not willing to do I
love it here's what I was going to
because you're actually saying the same
thing yeah literally what I just what
you describe is one of my ideas yeah you
called the white school I called the
wife Academy oh okay and it'll be an
amazing show I actually gave it to
somebody this is a free game I I gave it
to somebody but you said it already I um
I'm going to give it to the people wife
Academy would be a podcast where a woman
who's married brings in other women who
marry and talks them about what does it
mean to be a wife because the school is
cool but the school how many people can
be in the school 100 200 300 a thousand
is limited but it would be filmed so
it's like I love it yeah so so so let's
say you know it's it's gonna be filmed
so in his wife Academy the the
fundamental challenge is if you were
gonna start the wife Academy that people
want want to know did it work for you
that's the challenge with the women
because you are the face yeah you are
the best that's the whole like that's
like the whole idea is like I'd be going
through life school and I'd be like I'd
be giving feedback each round so I'd be
like all right I'll try this this week
I'll try that you know so it's like I
love it so because it reminds me of Anna
Bay School of Ellie School of affluence
yeah no I don't know what that is called
affluence she was the one she created
she very popular YouTube channel for
women teaching women how to be affluent
how to marry men in High Society this
down in the third yeah so her
information was like you said very
biographical as garyvee says document
don't create I'm not Theory I'm
documenting the journey and then
eventually she gets married gives all
types of credibility so you're 100 right
if you're gonna go that route where it's
like hey guys I'm not there yet I need
to learn I need to grow I need to
improve hear these expert women but the
point that I was bringing up was that
the true power in it when you go bananas
is when you're like yo I went through
white school and I got married yeah
because you're the face of it you're the
one bringing everybody together you are
the face no matter what you can bring
some amazing coming on to Wife School
wife Academy whatever you call it but
you're going to be the face but when
you're able to come in that room and be
like yo ladies welcome to White School
episode one my I'm your host just pearly
and and ladies no no I said I'm not I'm
going through it I'm talking about in
the future yeah yeah okay how many how
many times you're going through wife
school if you I don't know what's up
seven right now I don't know your time
I was starting before seven I'm giving
season seven right now okay
I'm using season seven this is how this
is how Steven seven is going to begin
hey how you doing today ladies it's just
pearly things and this is season seven
of Life School as you guys know
it worked for me you know and then you
know I mean you start flexing and I'm
telling you yeah women like women who
are where they want to be and so to me
one of my biggest things and like I said
just it's just I love what you said I
want to see more of that I want to see
that there's enough we know women modern
women are delusional we know the issues
in the divorce court we know that we
know these and we don't need more of it
we need you yeah but helping women I
disagree with you because like the one
thing I think it's it's common in our
space of YouTube to know this but it's
not common in like the general like I'm
on volleyball teams I'm on basketball
team like I I deal with a lot of
different types of girls from all walks
of life I don't think it's most girls
have any idea and that's actually part
of the stuff on my channel is like I
read pill women so I'll show them Jordan
Peterson about the pay Gap or I'll I'll
show them like so it's kind of like you
kind of see them go through their
Journey like first time but but my but
my thing is that and this maybe this is
my criticism of doing it for seven years
and maybe you're just sorry seven years
so huh this is my criticism of me doing
this for seven years okay and also me in
this in the um helping men since 2012
when I when I dropped my first YouTube
video I'm obsessed with Solutions and
the best Solutions right if you true if
we truly believe doing YouTube videos
showing people what's the what's wrong
in today's world is going to change the
minds of the masses you and I both know
that is not the case you and I both know
that's not the case that is not the
long-term solution to society if you
were to ask me what what would change
the world more you know pearly things
doing a wife Academy or wife school
where she's going through things that a
wife needs to be successful that she
goes through herself and then all of a
sudden she finds an amazing husband and
now she's having an amazing family and
using this example versus just going up
to random girls asking her do you
believe in female privilege what what do
what is most effective and so to me
that's the part where I realize my
expectations is not fair to put it on
you because it's your life it's your
purpose whatever you feel like God's
calls you to do but to me I after doing
this for so many years I'm like yo the
win is is the receipt is a result that's
the win in today's society the winning
today Society is what all the 40 year
old plus feminists single miserable
lonely yeah and they're and they're
upset and then their friends are happily
married doing well that's the win Sean
like yo you guys thought that 40 that 40
and 40 and which are cats is cool look
at you now that's the win is the receipt
so to me I want I I just don't think we
need more women just simply doing what
the guys are doing we already have the
guys doing that why don't the women such
as yourself who have the who have the
intelligence who have the ability to
encourage equip build up other women why
don't you guys do more of that and I
guarantee you that's what I'm trying to
do where's the wife Academy at it's um
we want to launch it in like February
March listen listen if you are for real
yeah I'm like dead seriously no no I'm
serious yeah if you are for real and you
are truly doing this I want to see it in
February I'm gonna I'm gonna and I'm
gonna that listen I'ma get your
information I'm gonna put it on my
calendar I'm gonna put February the
launch of wife school and you and
because what's happened is people have
told me they were gonna do stuff but
they saw the views they saw the money
and the other stuff because it's not
gonna be money in that initially and
that's gonna take you a lot of time
energy and effort oh I disagree I'm
entertaining you can't you can't not I
will make that show so entertaining I
will make it so entertaining and it's
gonna be good because I am the I am so
good at networking I can get really good
it's gonna be good if you if you really
believe that there's going to be more
views in wife School in white in the way
the way I'll do it yeah tell me how
you're gonna do it teach me it's gonna
be funny teach me yeah yeah so so
basically what I want to do is I want to
bring it's going to be me it's gonna be
my friend Jess yes but I'm also going to
bring in like the craziest 304s ever you
see now you gotta no you gotta make it
funny you gotta make it funny because I
like this is what I feel like you you
lose because you need to make it
entertaining to reach the most people
and that's you might not like that but
it's like the more people you reach the
the better your impact is if you and so
and and I'm sorry and you and you don't
know if those girl like you don't know
if those girls could be saved you have
no idea you have no idea here's the
reality you're 100 right if you want to
sell the most juice maximum Kool-Aid
minimum medicine and there's a j and
there's a balance there's a balance but
what you you're 100 True the less
medicine and the more Kool-Aid the more
people will buy it but then on the flip
side you get to the point where you're
like I want to reach the masses I want
to sell my drink to the masses and you
realize that the best way to sell your
drink to the masses do what give them
straight Kool-Aid not saying you're
giving them straight Kool-Aid but my I'm
you're losing me technology I need you
to dumb it down slightly so there's
there's this phrase about putting the
medicine in the Kool-Aid the Kool-Aid is
a drink okay the African-Americans
consume in two major flavors I know I
know oh you know Kool-Aid I know okay I
know what cool so so there's another so
there's a this person understand like
what was the medicine yeah yeah I'm
sorry okay I break it down okay there's
purple Kool-Aid you familiar with purple
Kool-Aid you guys might call it grape
Kool-Aid yeah I mean I know I never
drank it but I know what it is okay yeah
so there's something black people call
it purple Kool-Aid everyone else calls
it grape yeah there's another drink
called Robitussin it looks very very
similar it's good for your coughs good
for colds it's good for flues what ends
up happening is that when you want your
children to drink the robitussin have
you ever done drink Robitussin before no
you never drink Robitussin I don't know
if that is have you guys this is this is
what my people know my people know that
that's so this analogy was lost I was
like I don't even know what he's talking
about Robitussin is cough syrup okay
have you ever done cough syrup before
when you had a a sore thrower had quaffs
yeah yeah okay you had yet okay you
drunk I didn't know the name of it yeah
so when you drink cough syrup did it
taste good or did it taste bad uh it
tasted bad exactly so you put the cough
syrup in the Kool-Aid yeah so they said
they can drink it yeah and so they can
get the medicinal flavors yeah but then
they'll be able to digest it yeah here's
the problem it Waters it down right
here's a problem that eventually you
realize that if you really really want
them to drink the juice you have to
remove the cough syrup so it's this idea
of your right you're 100 right the more
entertaining things are the the more
views it get and I know this you said
this is why you lose no I knew this you
you didn't meet me because of you you
meet me back in 2010 just because we
were just simply just giving straight
facts a lot of people met me into that
2020 because of my live stream when I
was doing the live stream of the Pepe
soup and all that stuff I understand how
it worked Kevin Samuels talked a lot to
me about those things that he was doing
as well so I 100 know it works but what
I've also learned is that it comes a
time and a place where you realize that
the people all they want is the sugar
you fed them sugar all they wanted the
sugar they want no medicinal value if
you're truly trying to give them
medicine so sometimes you got to give
them the most you gotta find that
balance and that balance is not pure
entertainment so if you're truly if
you're truly which is which is why I'm
doing the school but yeah but when you
say it it's got to be bold when you told
when you said you're trying to bring
Brio whatever that red pill word is 304
I don't think it is if you're trying to
bring like like are you like that that's
Entertainment you're not even serious
yeah if you really if you really want
what's wrong what's wrong with being
entertaining it's not know what's wrong
with that there's nothing wrong with
being entertaining yeah but if you are
trying to help women become better and
you're telling me you can get 10 hoes
from down down off Crenshaw to be on the
show who are you who is the show for men
are for women who's you can't you can't
save hoes you can't help them stop
playing this game the only reason you
keep accusing me of playing games and
it's like a word where are you from
where are you from where are you from
where are you from well I'm from Chicago
suburbs oh my gosh yeah she'll know none
of the lingo you know what's going on
I've been in the UK for too long it's
just words girl no I I know having a
good time you okay yeah I'm having a
good time yeah I'm having a good time
you need a break no I'm like okay let's
we're having we're having fun games just
a word yeah yeah I understand yeah okay
guys we're having fun yeah so like I was
saying if you want to maximize helping
women and you're telling me you're gonna
do a show with the worst possible women
the most disresp rude rude me I'm going
on the show me no no I didn't say just
you and your camera different Jazz yeah
her just 10 hoes what is going on yeah
you got to make it out okay you got to
make it understanding I wouldn't I
wouldn't mind let me clarify if you had
one hope okay two hopes or should I
limit it I can make it three hoes if you
make it better because if you having a
few of them but don't tell me the show
was the and you haven't oh hoes stop it
I said two two nah now he's dead too no
no no no no I said I know I said me and
Justin's too that are and and all the
three old phones
real Florida Life School they need it
the most they needed the most
when it comes to teaching and I was a
teacher yeah you're going to be a
teacher in my school no no no no I'm a
student she's a student season what
happened season three all right maybe
okay
she can be teaching eventually yeah yeah
yeah here's the reality what's going to
happen you're gonna realize the best
student you want your students to be
successful why are you going this isn't
Coach Carter you know I mean this
doesn't lean on me they make the best
movement listen but you ain't the best
teacher you ain't the teacher that's
going to teach those people you ain't
gonna get the job done hey maybe I will
maybe so my thing they shoot for the
stars sure sorry I aim high healthy
she's shooting for the world star she's
shooting for The State Room sorry sorry
I understand it that's why I'm saying if
you want pure entertainment content yes
get the as you call them the 304s yeah
if you truly want to if you truly want
to be a place where it's like man
there's women who are health healthy who
are productive who are growing who are
improved and men are looking at that
like man man shout out pearly thing look
at all those amazing classy women that
are becoming wives and then all the
other women who want to be wives like yo
look at all these classy women who are
getting better I want to be a part of
that as well I'm seeing the results of
having as well that's truly
transformational versus just you you're
just having another Love and Hip Hop
because that sounds like you're trying
to make love of hip-hop but marriage and
Hip-Hop what's loving loving him what's
that stop it I'm done with you now I'm
done with you now I'm done with you now
I've done it
I'm not what you know and now I know
what game we're playing but but but so
to me lots of games here I love it I
love it we're having fun this is fun
that's that's my thing we're attitude of
content calling for what it is it's fun
when you were seriously didn't Kevin
Samuels made an impact do you think he
was trying to make Solutions and Kevin
Samuels was definitely not red pill you
wouldn't say no really no no
I guess they said these Godfather the
nanosphere Kevin is not see and like I
said I used to call it I knew a lot did
they not call him The Godfather or the
manners who but that's different than
red pill
manuscripts yeah yeah I guess yeah you
know what I mean like like like black
pill is part of the manosphere whole but
it's not red pill okay you know what I
mean it breaks down yeah fair enough so
a lot of and the reason why I always go
hard on the red pill stuff I knew a lot
of the people the ones I respect
personally I knew them personally I know
I knew some of the best content creators
for men personally on my phone right now
yeah but can I make the point with Kevin
Samuels I don't think he would have
reached as many people or had as much of
an impact if he did not make it
entertaining I don't think if he he was
like let me talk to the reasonable women
on my show I'll have as much of an
impact and I I honestly think that Kevin
Samuels changed like more lives than
anyone in the red like in the Manos I
think like he had the greatest impact
out of everyone here except maybe maybe
Andrew Teddy was a little bit more okay
here's the reality yeah you are are such
a smart woman and this is the this is
the Nuance of it yeah you're 100 right
and Kevin Kevin has said it himself if I
did not make the did not provide the
entertainment the masses would not
listen because the masses want the
entertainment but what Kevin Samuels
would also talk about is how he was
refining the message as Andrew Tate is
talking about as they're refining the
message to be able to better help the
masses but then you see it becomes
challenging right you didn't have a
challenge because then you get a certain
stigma on the message we understand
there's a little bit of locker room talk
a little bit of entertainment yeah what
happens is it becomes a little bit more
difficult so what I'm saying is that
every generation needs to do it better
right if we're saying okay he was able
to maximize reaching the masses but then
the message got lost because of the
entertainment because because of certain
things so my biggest thing is that okay
do you think his message got lost Kevin
Samuels I think Kevin Samuel's message
got lost a lot of people and I think
Kevin Samuels was in potentially doing
things to improve it and that's why I
respect Kevin so much because Kevin grew
same with Andrew Tate they understood
that therefore when you're talking to
the masters of people versus a thousand
people five thousand people they
understood these things and they
continue to improve of course you you
improve at your craft over time yes yeah
but yeah but but you asked me did the
message get lost did it get lost to
everybody of course not yeah but what
they understood which is why they grew
because there is a better way of doing
things I've grown right and so to me
when I'm communicating to you is that if
you're gonna do content you should look
at the people for you and don't just
simply try to get the most attention
because a lot of times people play this
altruistic game like I just want to help
no you wanna you want views you want
attention you want followers you want
dollars oh you can't deny that and to
deny this being is being facetious there
there is a benefit of being the most
entertaining popping YouTube channel
there is a selfish benefit none of us
are perfect from it but my biggest thing
is that when you realize you know what I
truly want to impact the most
individuals and if I'm gonna do that
bring in the most ratchet girls on a
show called White Academy do you know
what so-called Charm School on bh1 yeah
or Bad Girls Club Charm School someone
when I was explaining this idea somebody
told me about China yeah or Bad Girls
Club that's exactly what you're trying
to do yeah like that to me is like yo
that's just pure VH1 reality show
garbage if you're truly trying to make a
change but find teachable women there's
a whole community of teachable women in
today's world who want to learn who want
to grow who want to be better wives
because if you make it the most
entertaining show then you get the
people that actually want to learn no
that's because it hits because you hit
the most people so the one it resonates
with it's not just gonna be like I told
you I'm gonna be doing it here's the
reality you you and I both understand
audience capture yeah let's keep it 100
because you either you're oblivious to
how YouTube works or you're being
utterly delusional in front of your
people which I don't believe you're
delusion I believe you're very smart
women so I hope it's not that you're
oblivious to this is how it works there
is audience capture here perfect example
if I am going to make um Chick-fil-A
what kind of food do I want I want
chicken my mindset going here is I want
chicken if Chick-fil-A starts serving
Seafood I don't want Seafood from
Chick-fil-A so Chick-fil-A has captured
an audience that wants these things so
for for Content creators if your primary
form of content is let's say playing
video games you're like you know what
I'm gonna do video game content to be
able to reach the masses and all of a
sudden I'm gonna then teach my my my
rocket science but it wouldn't just be
hoes that's what I'm telling you I'm
doing it too I'm the main character on
my channel no I'm the main character yes
I am you literally just said it's you
your friend in a bunch of hoes you're
not being serious yeah let's keep so
let's stop playing this game this is why
it's not it's not a game this is why the
Redfield people you guys are acting dumb
you know what you're doing point you
know you're doing this for them no I I
have a stop playing this game I have a
hundred percent said it is going to be
an entertaining show your brain I also
don't want to learn come on how do you
how do you know they don't want to learn
you said that biggest thing yeah
you can you can trick the people in
there you're not sure I'm not tricking
anybody why do you keep you keep like
accusing me of things and it's just like
yeah okay okay are you is this too much
for you no I can calm down no I thought
we were having fun okay you want
entertainment right you want views
you're the one who said you want
entertainment okay now I'm giving you
entertainment
you want entertainment having a good
time okay we're having a good time
ladies and gentlemen my point is that I
understand that you have to provide
entertainment and when you make things
stale like broccoli nobody's gonna want
it I understand that but what I'm saying
is that if you're telling me the biggest
issue that's that's destroy join Society
is is the point that you brought up
about the man the issues between
marriage and you believe your solution
is a Academy for women well as long as
you get the women who want to actually
learn why won't you get the healthy
positive women the way I think about it
is I'm gonna have more screen time
anyway and then you get like the it's
like you always want a contrast to
personalities and you're trying to make
it funny and so it's like it's funny or
is it be helped I think what's the
problem I think you can do both and
maybe maybe you feel like it can only be
one maybe maybe can you can you let me
you keep cutting me off as much it's
actually my Channel today it's my
Channel today it's not like and it's
like I I I think you can be entertaining
and helpful at the same time I just
think I just think you reach the most
people through entertainment and I I
feel like if if you have an entertaining
and you have one character that's
actually trying to learn or two
characters that are actually trying to
learn it's like you're they're trying to
overtake like the world of hoes and it's
like then then you can see the
progression and I I feel like you'll
still have people that want to learn
that'll sign up but that's just my
that's just my think about it what so
Michael like like I'm I'm going to have
more screen time than the other girls
because it's my show so here's a
question yeah season three you end up
getting married uh-huh you're no longer
on the show because you obviously can't
be no sorry you can't be in this school
multiple seasons are you getting kept
back no no I'm in the lab of season two
oh you're right yeah then I would host
you're right you're right yeah yeah
think about it you can't if you're if
you're in if you are in marriage Academy
for seven years in a row you're like yo
something's wrong with this chick right
here I'm seeing this seven years yeah so
after season one yeah then we coach yeah
now you're now you're gonna be now
you're gonna be coaching yeah who's all
going to be in an audience who's gonna
be in the audience who's gonna be the
students now well it's kind of like
like it would be you would you would
have a mix it would be a mix 50 50 90
10. I don't know if he's I'm just trying
to get season one out okay do you I I
really haven't thought about season two
three four and you keep trying to like
Hammer me out the details I thought
honestly you told me this you had a plan
I thought you had a plan
one year three year five years not
really honestly this whole this whole
content creation thing I've just kind of
like done the best I can I don't really
think I had to be fair but I know yeah
but it's like it works out pretty well
I'm almost at 500k subscribe subscribe
honestly that to me if I'm being real I
know a lot of you guys love those
numbers to me those numbers don't mean
anything okay because about it's about
generally what are you out to do because
I think like and this is where am I
picking on you a lot of people in the
space they genuinely the scoreboard is
views it's subscribers it is dollars the
scoreboard for me is seeing men's lives
transform is seeing actual healthier
families in today's society seeing the
system and seeing seeing all those
unhealthy things no longer existing and
now there's better men better women
better better future that's a scoreboard
for me and so at the end of the day
every single decision that we make
should be for the purpose of creating
healthier men and women in the future
and so if you're if the scoreboard go
ahead now I lost my train of thought
yeah go ahead
it's a scoreboard is simply if you use
likes and subscribers and then I respect
that I'll keep it 100. keep it 100 I'm
not mad at it why can't you do both why
does it have to be one or the other you
can't do both but be honest you can't do
anything if you don't make money but
here's the deal yeah like but be honest
what you're doing all right what are you
if you're being 100 real primarily can
you be honest primarily it because
there's no thing is like 50 50. so
there's no perfect
what's that word asymmetrical split
right if you're being honest you're just
building this as you fly you don't know
these things you're new here you don't
really know what's going on and so to me
I'm not holding you to the same things I
hold myself to a lot of those other
content creators they're older men
they've been doing this for a long time
there's a lot of wisdom that I'm like yo
I'm a 32 year old man I'm just figuring
life out I'm a young man I don't have
the wisdom of these older dudes so I
hold them to higher standards you we're
just having fun you're new here yeah
you're just figuring stuff out you're
just copying pasting some of their what
they say to you you're trying this out
you're gonna learn you're gonna be
better five years from now you'll be a
totally different person how old are you
I'm 25. you're super young you're young
see I don't I never get mad at the the
young red pill guys and girls I don't
because you guys are young it's like
it's like a young feminist oh yeah I
don't want no babies 25 sure I'll see
you at 35 with your beautiful husband
and your children and so to me my
pushback is I get that you're not where
I get that you're not where you need to
be right now and it's okay because
you're on your journey but my biggest
thing is that if we are being honest and
we're saying that if this is the big
like they're telling me the biggest
issue in today's society is to break
down the family the biggest issue is the
law if these are the biggest issues and
I'm like why is not 90 80 70 of the
energy being put into these things if
this is truly the biggest issue I truly
believe the biggest issue is that we're
not building strong competent men that's
why I sacrifice everything that I own
and everything that I've done to put all
my energy into that I am as Pastor Beth
David said that David said A True
Believer in what I'm communicating and
so to me I just got to be honest if
you're simply doing this for fun for
views for life you're just figuring
things out call it for what it is but
let's not play this game like we're
these altruistic individuals who don't
care about these other things when we do
I've never played a game where I pretend
that I don't want to make money and get
subscribers like I want that too but I
just think you can do both I think you
can advocate for men and make money at
it I don't see the problem and the
reality and I don't I think you can
start to build Solutions and make money
like I think everything like you can't
build anything without money you can't
build that like nothing
no one's doing a charity if you're
telling me my my goal is to help men and
I need to make money but the way I'm
making money is hurting a man you're I'm
not hurting much you don't you said you
I didn't say you okay
yeah but I'm like why are you taking
this person I'm not am I am I hitting a
sore spot that's how you is this what
bothers you at night no no you're not
hitting anything are you sure yeah
I'm having a good time guys but it's
like it's like I don't know I just I
think you can do both of course yeah but
my so my thing is that as you grow you
realize that dang some of the stuff I
was doing yesterday was I thought was
which I thought was good it's not
beneficial today it's not moving people
for forward today it's not helping men
and women today once you understand
those things then you as the individual
can adjust can improve and you will you
definitely will you're 25 you're just
you're new to the space you're gonna get
so much better and so what I'm what I'm
communicating is that if there was a
healthy balance right we've gone on too
far on the entertainment side and we're
not on into the true life transformation
side and in regards not saying you
not saying you but I'm saying the
content in general and that's what I've
seen because I've been watching this
content for a long time you're new here
I've been watching this for a very very
long time people that you mentioned I've
been watching them for a very very long
time and to me there is an evolution and
there's a growth which I love what I was
seeing out of Kevin I love what I'm
seeing out of Andrew Tate and that's
what we need to make the society a
better place and that's all I'm
advocating for I think
like you think role of tomasi I
was like
Solutions these are the tools you need
Solutions I thought I thought it was I
thought it was a proxology not ideology
well look the fine familiar practology
let's stop right there Define you want
me to look it up or do you want to look
it up you can look it up I won't curious
based on I'm not a smart guy I'm just a
guy who likes to read books and share my
opinion I want to know what a practology
is I want to know a praxology I'm not
smart guys I miss a guy a praxology is a
Theory Of Human Action based on the
notion that humans engage in purposeful
Behavior am I is this the right one
never looked up the definition I don't
know but how would you use a word never
look at the definition
um I said that's what they say oh so you
don't know yeah I don't know she's just
you're just going off what they said
yeah okay cool yeah I told you guys you
got to study these things you got you
got to study it for yourself you can't
just listen to somebody else and then go
what they say look it up yourself just
be a blind witness yeah sorry I don't
have the definition of apraxiology
memorized yeah well if you're using the
word hopefully you know what it means
I'm not gonna throw a word out there I
don't even know what that word means
because Jack and Jill no I thought it
was like like my understanding of the
study of human action and conduct yeah
like my my understanding was this it's
like based on like reality and it's
based on like data it's not like uh
ideology is like how you view the world
and itraxiology is like based on what is
that that's mine ideology is a system of
ideas and ideals if you have a solution
to a problem that is an idea and so
therefore everyone has a unique set of
ideas everyone has a unique set of
solutions and a unique set of ideas and
solutions create someone's ideology so
therefore when you use the word
praxeology which you did not know what
it meant you just heard somebody else
said and then dispute it out therefore
what I'm trying to communicate is that
well I said that's what they said that's
what I said you heard what someone else
said yes yes yeah and the initial point
which I was saying initially is that too
many people when they hear talking
points online they simply regurgitate
them they never analyze them for
themselves everything that I said guys
I'm just a man who likes to read books
and share my opinion I'm not Dr Jordan B
Peterson I'm not Dr David Buss I'm
simply a man let's read a book and share
my opinion everything that I say men and
women study yourself investigate
yourself because that to me is a end
destination and so my biggest point in
this conversation was that everybody has
a system of practices so you said that
individual whatever that guy's name yeah
has Solutions oh wait great I'm curious
what is what is his Solutions oh so he
does money muscle game frame and so it's
like if you want to get better with
women it's like get your money up your
muscles gain game and then so they're
telling they're telling men what to do
yeah okay interesting yeah interesting
so I think he
feels that he gives men this is
and you can
I want them to but this is like your
interview okay I just I just know my
rule of thumb is I know how certain
people act that you you mentioned their
name is like freaking like mentioned
Bloody Mary and pop up in the mirror I
don't want I want to focus on you and me
conversation other people other content
creators if they're not in the room
let's not talk about them okay okay what
is your position on marriage then to me
marriage is the greatest blessing you'll
ever have in your life or can also be
the greatest burden you'll ever have in
your life it's the single most important
decision that you'll make in your life
and it's a serious decision that people
don't take seriously and have huge
ramifications I truly believe marriage
and family the family is a foundation of
society if there is no family that
Society is run by the state and that's
what nobody wants I'm not sure your
political views but most people don't
want a society that's run by the state
we don't want communism we don't want
socialism we need strong independent
families leading strong independent
communities and so I totally understand
that marriage is a foundation of it but
at the same time choose the wrong woman
worst burden ever choose the right women
greatest blessing ever what do you think
about prenups did you get a prenup no no
prenup no I totally agree if you're a
man you want prenups I'm not a money guy
there's other things that we talked
about and we we've obviously conversed
with money is not important to me
everybody is different you know what I
mean and so if you're a man you want on
a pre-number you when we want to print
up all power to be be to it um one of
the things out me my friends had a great
conversation about prenups and I said
the reality of it is the state has rules
if your marriage falls apart so you
should have rules yourself so this is
what I I was talking to Adam about about
the marriage marital agreement people
don't realize prenup is like a prime
like a a smaller version of a marriage
agreement because prenup is only when
it's only a few things but there's a lot
more things that you need to have in
your marriage I.E what happens if you
and I pass away in a car accident who
who are who do our kids get raised by
it's a lot of things that you need to be
able to sit down with your partner and
talk about so to me a prenup is just the
beginning you need to have a whole
agreement where you talk about all these
nuanced conversations and topics to be
able to benefit your marriage in the
long run do you think that men
do you think that men or women are more
to blame for the high divorce rate or do
you think do you think it's primarily
men because and here's why okay who is
the leader in society man well actually
no you don't know it's like women to
make 70 to 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions who's a leader I'm curious to
your people camera put it on our camera
yeah tell the people who's the leader in
society no matter you're right men lead
so she believed women women have a lot
of power in society today but but
who leads men or women man yeah right
yeah if men are the leaders and your
team loses you play volleyball you
played division one sports you know this
thing I play D1 oh stop it if you I wish
if you yeah are the leader of your team
the team loses what should the leader do
whose fault is it then when the
quarterback loses the game his receiver
drops the touchdown what does the
quarterback say when the interview ask
him why did we lose the game he takes
accountability even even if there was
something that other people didn't
contribute to the loss the quarterback
never throws his team under the bus
which is why Ron Riviera the Redskins
head coach everybody got mad at him
because he blamed Carson Wentz for
losing is Carson Wentz playing good heck
no he's playing like garbaggio but the
court the coach cannot go before the
audience and say oh the the reason we're
losing because of him you're the leader
put that on your back are there things
that women have done and feminism has
done to contribute to the breakdown
Society 100 000 but man I thought we
were the leaders I know we were in
charge how did we let this day happen
how do we let it get to this place so me
personally I understand that if you're
going to be the leader you get the final
say and you get the responsibility when
the team loses I actually kind of agree
with that
yeah because because I think women
wanted a certain amount of power and
like men gave it to them like who
developed birth control it was men but I
do think like it's kind of on the women
though too because we asked for it and
so it's like it's like if you're gonna
ask for it then you can't be mad at the
consequences and now but the problem is
now I think now women have more power
than men like that's just right like we
make 70 to 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions and we we make up and they
it's been proven that women decide
elections if you truly believe that the
power I feel like I'm Andrew Tate right
now the power in today's world is being
held in the hands of women you are
deceiving yourself you think the global
Elites are a bunch of women who are
ruining the world this is not the one
this is not Wonder Woman see I haven't
gotten to the elite stage of red pill
yet the elites that's like a that's like
a term I haven't gotten there yet if you
think who's running the world are women
you do not understand the way the world
Works men have men Run the World men
have the power Just because they give
women a little bit of consumer spending
Goods to be able to shop on useless
things on Amazon it's because they give
individuals a right to vote occasionally
this you think the men are not ruining
this world yeah maybe a small no okay
okay a small percentage but women we're
the ones that are bailed out of every
bad decision we make who make who allows
those rules who yeah why do they allow
but then at the same time who elects
those people women decided democracy in
the U.S women decide elections you think
this is a democracy here you think this
is a free demography see where the
people are choosing the leaders come on
you're too young for this uh-huh I don't
think women decide elections we make
we're more do you really believe okay
the the the the the power in the Free
World is being decided they're letting
people freely decide the elections you
think it didn't want somebody in power
they're not going to make sure this
person's not going to be in power my
point okay so you you like you're on the
the voter I'm just having fun okay no no
I don't I don't you gotta get because
the red pill conspiracy this is their
this is their redness I don't I don't
subscribe to them I know stealing
elections I didn't say stealing
elections that's what it seemed like
you're right I never said anything about
suing elections okay I never say
anything about stealing elections I'm
just communicating certain ideas and so
my point when you asked me you said who
is at fault I cannot say I'm a man men
are the leaders and then blame it do
women have a responsibility to the
destruction Society of course they do
but men are the leaders it stops with us
a man had to make this Allah a man had
to say this was okay but the women
elected them I don't know so you believe
that the women are electing the men and
then the men are so so you believe the
women of the master puppeteers were
electing the the political pundits to do
their bidding I'm telling you right now
if you truly if you really believe that
the powers in Russia the powers in China
the powers all over these World
superpowers are being run because of a
woman electing somebody into office I'm
telling you right now you might need a
little bit more political research
how are we Trend towards communism
so
I don't I don't know I just think I I
agree with you like I do think men lead
and so I think the power they gave to
women like like they did give it to us
explain North Korea explain China didn't
you think China gave power to women you
said you said lean into her communism
you said you think China gave power to
women that's why they're leading towards
communism they
get back to relationship politics now
let's let's stay in relationships so
back to the relationships who is the
major person that's at fault in regards
to the breakdown of the families do
women have a role yes but I call men the
leader so men are primarily responsible
do you think men are more different
today or women are more different today
than the 1940s I think I honestly think
it's both and here's why testosterone
levels that men are at all time what
well all time low you know this stuff
right if you know these things so of
course 100 if if men
the the man in in
1944 I always butchered a year who
invaded Normandy are they the same men
today who are who are who are wearing
their blue hair and their pronouns are
him heard and zip and said and are those
the same men that were invaded normally
back in the day there are some weird
male feminists come on man you think
those you need the same ones
I'm like oh yeah the dude's wearing
dresses yeah these are the same guys
that were back in the 1940s no you're
right come on come on what are we
talking about so that's one of my
arguments is like fellas are half women
devolved heck yeah but look at what the
Kevin we ask them to they'll be like but
why did you listen man you are in charge
of women right
don't listen to somebody when they're
telling you to do the wrong thing as a
leader it's like it's like you use an
example that people don't like if I am
the parent and my child told me I want
cotton candy every day for the rest of
my life you're saying you women are
children I told you I'm using the
example and we're going to get we're
going to get the people going we are a
little bit we're having fun here we're
having fun if you have a child and that
child said they want cat and candy for
every single day for the rest of your
life and you are the leader you are in
charge and that then that child says
they wanted what do you do do you just
simply say the child is crying I give
him the cotton candy or do you say I'm
in charge I'm the leader what's best for
you is this you're not getting that
nonsense not foolishness what do you say
I'm curious you're smarter than me
please teach the people you should just
give the kid whatever they want I love
it because exactly I'm just kidding just
kidding just listen to the four-year-old
listen to the four-year-old so my my
point is that if you are the leader and
you're responsible for somebody you have
to make the best decisions and even if
the decision makes them upset you got to
do what makes them healthy and in the
long run so that's my personal opinion
on these things
do you think that polygamy could be a
solution going forward yeah no because
polygamy would destabilize society and
this is what blows my mind about the red
pill and the red pill some of the red
pill guys always talking about how a
high value management exercises options
imagine that's how you know that's how I
started what's because my dad's in the
like that like in that category and I
called him I'm like Dad where are your
hoes you're supposed to have some oh
Lord Jesus I was I was so confused I was
like I didn't grow up there like this
listen listen so this is a different
world like yeah we got to do a lot of
when they were explaining I was like wow
this is very different you took some
drank the Kool-Aid you're fully in it
but I did it hopefully by the end of
today's you know you realize I don't I
don't first like I don't agree with
cheating I've never said I agreed with
cheating I just said you drank the
Kool-Aid no no no no no drink something
isn't that doesn't that mean like then
then like I'm apart doesn't that mean
that that I have a different opinion on
it I thought that's what that meant when
you said you drank the Kool-Aid what I'm
saying is that there's certain
ideologies and beliefs that you have
that I I when you when I hear you say
them I'm like dang all right I remember
that video where somebody uttered that
idea and I'm like man did she copy and
paste this or does she genuinely believe
it and so going back to the point well I
just if things make sense to me if
someone has a good argument like why
would I not repeat it if I've researched
it and I think it's a good argument I've
just seen some of the things you haven't
researched so my my rule of thumb is
like the definition of apraxiality 100
okay okay 100 because you you call me
yellow and you said it's not an ideology
it's a practiology you don't know what
that word even means off the top of my
head no you're right I just had a
general idea okay cool okay so in
regards to ask me about polygamy it
destabilizes Society here's why think
about a guy like an Andrew Tate Andrew
Tate is tall he's handsome and
successful if Andrew Tate was like I
want everybody's girl he can Genghis
Khan this whole planet he could yeah
and here's the reality for the average
guy it doesn't benefit him because if
you even if you've seen freaking um
Braveheart right obviously it's a
fictional movie but it's an example with
Prima nocte going on in Scotland there
was a time of the day where if a dude
wanted your woman they pull up and they
take your woman what are you gonna do
about it I'm in charge and so I've never
seen Braveheart but you're missing out
on me okay 2.5 percent of your life it's
a movie 2.5 of your life is missing you
haven't watched Braveheart my point of
it and this is why like I had so much
respect from when Andrew Tate was
talking about male promiscuity wasn't a
good thing because as a guy if you want
if if guys wanted to take all they could
play that Genghis Khan game and that
would disrupt society and you think men
today are complaining about one third of
men don't have sex and all the Chads and
tyrones are having sex and not me let
let polygamy be normal let the game let
them let them let the flood waters
really really let free and so to me I
truly believe that destabilizing society
and they create an equal opportunity for
all men we have to be able to say no one
man one woman what do you think if it
was like they could have multiple but it
would be like capped be like this Islam
this is
what the [ __ ] you thought that was like
would you would you feel the same way
because wouldn't it be it would be like
polygamy but it wouldn't be like on
stair like no Genghis Khan's out here
yeah yeah so so that's that that's
Islam's argument right is Islamic
community's arguments that but it also
destabilizes Society because think about
it right now you're a numbers girl like
I said you're smarter than me yeah let's
say we had a hundred women and there was
99 men let's say 99 men in society right
100 women 99 men how can every man get
four wives how many wives how many men
can get four-wise you know what I mean
so so it eventually that's kind of what
it is now though and you and you told me
that's the problem yeah you're right and
that's why I'm so passionate I'm like yo
you if you truly believe the problem in
today's world is promise QD is a few
women going to all the chats and Tyrone
how can you ascribe to this high value
management exercises option and be able
to have multiple women no I don't not
subscribe to that yeah yeah of course
would you say you I I think because like
when you when you say you like I think
you're talking about me because it's me
and you no so like if I say you like I
would think that you know I'm sorry I'm
talking yeah okay okay
beautiful people on camera oh okay so so
that's what I'm trying to communicate
and so at the end of the day I realized
that if you're trying to really help
Society one man can't have 10 15 20
girls it's not gonna help us it's not
going to help it average dude in Indiana
it's not fair so in my dad when I when I
told my dad that he was like yeah have
these guys try one wife before they
drive and let's talk about it so to me
my number one my my second pushback one
of my many 75 pushbacks on the red pill
Audiology is like if you've had one wife
having three to me is like torture I'm
being honest with you not saying my one
wife is I'm saying having three because
those three are competing for your time
energy and attention I come my name is
Hafiz my office is not an African name
ignorant people it's not a Nigerian name
sadly educated people is an Arabic name
my family's all Arabic most of every
male in my family my dad's side of the
family is Muslim I come from a
polygamous background the reality of the
matter is polygamous families have
issues they have issues it's not
freaking Bliss what issues are they
because I don't know anyone that
personally like grew up with that so I'm
just curious Give an example you have
women like you okay you're the smart
wife you're intelligent you're
submissive you do everything the right
way you're attractive everything is
great the six up then the husband says I
want to spend more time with you I want
I want your kids to go to the best
schools I want your kids every night oh
so it's like a favor and not how the
other women gonna feel about you they're
gonna hate does it does it come and go
because I'd imagine like there'd be
Seasons because everyone's got pros and
cons or does does he usually have a one
favorite that's like always the favorite
every few you can't have 10 women I have
one favorite yeah well I'm just thinking
like in a friend group like I'll have
one favorite but then you know she might
annoy me and then like it'll switch you
know but you but you deep down inside no
there's a friend that you naturally get
along with more than everybody else it
may be seasonal when you get along with
somebody else but over the long span of
a friendship I I naturally gravitate
towards it so it's kind of like there's
like jealousy that builds up because he
doesn't what's the most wives one of
your like I said it's not I can't talk
on behalf of my family because my dad
doesn't want me talking about these
things publicly okay um but you know
what's the most wives you've seen or
like personally people don't so um in
Nigeria I'm Nigerian there's three major
tribes yes
most night dream that you meet in the
western world are Yoruba and Evo I've
met ebo you rarely meet hausa you will
never they stay in Nigeria houses are
predominantly Muslims those guys 20 25
30 like those they will keep on taking
and keep on taking but some of them be
like the religion holds them back but
you gotta think about it the religion
capsum at four but how many people
really follow their religion all the way
you know what I mean like Christianity
Christianity said you shouldn't have sex
until marriage
okay because I live in London and so
like there's a lot of I I've had so many
Nigerians on my I feel like Nigerian
people just really like to share their
opinions but I don't know why because
our culture especially evos I don't know
I don't I don't understand the tribes I
don't know the background this is just
I've had so many ebos
on my show and they're all yeah but
um yeah I actually forgot where I was
going with you were saying that the
Nigeria I was making a point about
having multiple wives the Nigerian uncle
they always say like like be careful of
the Nigerian Uncle because it's in
London because what will happen is
they're like he'll spoil it like this is
they said it like because I've heard
them reference this and I do this
mysterious Nigerian uncle that Hill
he'll spoil you and whatever but he has
a whole family 100 that's what they do
that's what they do yeah unfortunately
part of the coach of polygamist culture
so yeah to the original question yeah
stabilize the society and that's why I'm
just like if you're really trying to
help men you know know that you need to
you need to tell hey man you guys need
one it's then so the other guys can have
more think about like you said you want
to incentivize women incentivize what
you want to see more if the women
realize that hey you're not going to be
so-and-so side chick you're not going to
be so-and-so's fourth and fifth wife
you're gonna have to lower your
standards yeah it will change them like
you said it will change them but if
every woman knows you know I can be I
can be Futures number 17. I can beat
social number 15. like then it's going
to continue to create this issue that
we're having in today's world yeah it's
just like my thing is I feel like you
can't change like certain things that
just are and I always say I don't feel
bad for a single girl that got cheated
on by a pro athlete you either do I I
don't I don't have a bit of sympathy I
don't like you knew what you signed up
for just like come on or rapper or
rapper seriously like you have that
freaking you know Jason Derulo of course
she's like going online like crying like
oh he cheat I'm like he's humping girls
on stage Even Adam Even Adam Levine is
like really he's Adam
I'm not gonna say what they should and
shouldn't do because it's like they work
to get to that point you know and so and
so and I can't change the way the world
just like is you know and so when you
have someone that's like good looking
they have clout that because I would say
like most of the millionaires like the
the rich people I know we're kind of
nerds like nerds aren't really no I mean
I know Bill Gates was on his wild ship
but like so like that's why I would say
the community I was in like wasn't that
it wasn't that big with that but I'm
like yeah if you want to be a part of
that lifestyle that just kind of comes
with it and I'm not I'm not here to tell
them what to do or tell them how to live
their life but it's just like Ladies If
you go for that type of guy that's what
comes with it here's my pushback to you
yeah I I agree with you but to a point
the men can't lie my problem with Adam
I don't know this whole story is that if
they lied yeah am I saying he did it
yeah my thing is that if you are that
kind of guy you should let her know up
front because I I play college football
a lot of my friends played in the NFL
they're the men are not masculine enough
to be look at the woman in the eyes and
be like yo I'm gonna have others I'm
gonna be on tour I'm gonna be in
different cities there will be others I
will never you know no no babies no
whatever the rules that they have for
their yeah but my problem is when the
guys live I agree with you
if you're an athlete be 100 say yo I'm
gonna be on tour I'm gonna do my thing
if you want it you can stay if you don't
you can leave but even but even I still
don't even if the girl gets lied to as
an NFL player I'm like I still don't
feel bad it's like you even if you like
come on I agree what did you think was
gonna happen I think I think to me Jason
Derulo's baby mama I'm talking to you I
got so mad when I saw that freaking that
story and everyone's like oh that poor
woman and I'm like no yeah nasty I'm
like you've dated like 10 athletes they
probably all cheated on you and now
you're shocked when he does it after you
have a kid and now you're gonna leave
after you have the baby when he's
humping girls on stage stop it listen
stop it pearly you you told no lies in
your whole monologue right there and to
me I agree with you 100 the and my rule
of thumb is a man you gotta be honest
and you gotta have it on contract you're
an athlete you make them sign ndas
you're an artist these girls
are Reckless I'm like yo what a reckless
I make them sign these [ __ ] Instagram
models without ndas are you stupid why
are you using your account
are you dumb are you what is going on
yes to me sometimes I'm like you're
right the girl is like but the guy's
like you're just dumb bro like Adam
Levine's girl is like yeah I knew what
it was yeah hey what's going on I'm like
so I'm not gonna shame like for me it's
like I'm not gonna shame those guys for
doing that but like people think I'm
confusing that with like saying oh you
should cheat you drank the Kool-Aid I'm
like I didn't drink the Kool-Aid I just
that's what the world is and so it is
what it is I think I think the hardest
part to me is I just don't like you're
right it's like a naive thing but I
gotta be 100 honest there are some
athletes who don't do it there are some
not all of them is it one percent two
percent I don't know the number right
yeah or some apps so so to me what I
don't like and I I love I love about I
love guys being honest yeah don't play
like you're the nice guy who doesn't
cheered after the game I just go home
and sleep and watch Netflix like don't
lie okay but Devil's Advocate I I think
women we know when dude's getting laid
stop it stop it stop it we and like what
they'll do is they'll pretend like oh oh
I didn't know I had no idea why'd you
check his phone 10 times stop it you you
knew like there's a part of you you knew
he was gonna cheat you did not get
bamboozled you just like the guy that
can cheat and and I won't feel bad for
you and I think the amount of times I've
been on this show the girls love the
cheaters because I swear to God I have
had girl after girl after girl it's like
they love telling these stories they
love they love they love that's always
the facts they talk about the most and
hate is closer to love so it's like you
love him here here I I it's funny enough
I was on jedediah's podcast and she
played a clip that you played about
women loving cheaters here is the
reality there's a clip about women
loving cheaters you were talking to this
one girl about life oh she played me on
the podcast oh I didn't I didn't know I
was okay yeah I did I didn't know I was
on the show yeah yeah yeah you know what
I'm talking about I talk for
anyway so she's playing a clip of you
that you talk about how women love
cheaters and so you made that point but
it's not that she loves the cheater she
loved the cheater then she wouldn't
complain about the cheater what she
loves is what the cheater brings to her
right so usually
well there is some of that but usually
who's a cheater is a cheater you know
Joe Blow working at McDonald's that
these women are crazy about sometimes
it's not trust me it's not if it was
dope you'll be surprised some bums have
a lot of free time but here's the reason
yeah there's one guy that came on my
show he was telling me about his
rotation I'm like this man barely was a
he was a SoundCloud rapper but here's a
hypnosis
women call men bums but they don't
really understand women are seeing in
him oh just because you don't have a job
doesn't mean that you're bummed women
you might be Saucy he might be swaggy he
might have a certain genocide being
charismatic he's a he's making they have
the time to do it exactly so to me
there's a level of attraction yeah true
that these men have and when you and
when you can attract her you can attract
her her her and her and so to the point
of men women just liking to cheat her
women like men who other women want and
the men the other women want are usually
the men who will want to cheat so
therefore it's I just want to bring
bring that to the equation because I
don't it's just not simply like because
I know there's a guy like well I'm gonna
cheat on my girlfriend and then if you
don't want me no bro she's not gonna
want you no matter what you do you're
not attracted to her that's your problem
go find somebody else but it's you
become if you're really that guy and
other women do find you attractive that
is some of the things that's when you
hear these women tell the story because
that guy turned them on so much yeah but
the problem is it's like I ask it's like
I I've done these shows so many times I
just see the same story in different
people I'm sure you've had a similar
like 100 yeah and it's the same story
like okay he cheated did you leave no
when did you leave when he stopped like
like you ask enough questions they
always leave when he stops cheating or
he's not cheating it's like why don't
you leave when he cheated no here's what
happened here's what happened it's not
that they left when he stopped cheating
they left when she can mostly be mostly
detached so here's what happens a woman
will be with a guy cheats on her hurts
on her because it continues to hurt her
she cannot leave at that moment she's
emotionally attached to her she cannot
go from she has to slowly pull away and
slowly detach but in the meantime she
doesn't want to rock the boat she won't
think that she's about to leave it
should be nice she'd be sweet should be
to be kind so in that season usually I
found that's when the guy's chilling out
he's like you know what I'm chilling out
you know what I mean I'm not doing as
much not in the streets as much she's
getting better we're getting better you
think if he cheated again she would
still like she would leave Ben I think I
I think so so say like he cheats once
and then the second time he cheats do
you think she would leave because
depending on the woman depending on her
back or depending on her mental state
depending on how much you love chaos
depending on if it's so many different
yeah no it's just like the the thing
with me is like a lot of them will say
he did it multiple times but they always
leave when he stops well and it's just
it's just weird but it's not true that
the moment he stopped cheating because
how would she know he stopped cheating
she she was always
the moment the moment that's that's the
moment the moment like she stops finding
evidence of him yeah it's just weird to
me here's what I'm saying what I've
learned is talking this is why I stopped
doing a lot of things that I did when
you're talk when you're talking to women
and you're doing these interviews and
you have these lights and you have these
beautiful black magic cameras they're
not going to tell you the honest truth
and when you give women direct questions
in front of Lights in front of a camera
they're not telling the truth that's why
all the respect to your guy I didn't
want to do a show not because I don't
want to shout him out if he had a
one-on-one Pockets I would do it but
women are not as honest in front of
Lights in front of the camera because
for them expressing logical truths is
not the best if you want to express
emotions ask her the better question was
okay when you eventually left him how
did you feel about him and when did that
feeling start because usually what you
figure out is that that emotion was
dying she cut it off months ago it was
dying off I agree with it so she stopped
searching for cheating yeah she stopped
caring about the thing because she was
mostly checked out I don't know I just I
think like sometimes as women we kind of
like the drama unhealthy women do I I
just think yeah there's a part of Do You
Love drama do you want do you love a man
who's gonna keep on cheating on you
smacking you up beside your head calling
you names oh God you said drama
that's a lot of drama some people you
say they love drama what more is better
hey some people like you that sounds
like it would hurt some people like it
uh do you like it do I like drama yeah
like ever I mean I watched the
Kardashians
I think there's some innate part of
women in general that tends to like
drama I'm not saying all women of course
they like drama but here's a reality
people are using that word drama
incorrectly what's going on is that for
healthy women like yourself you to
describe your father shout out to your
father and your beautiful mother Shadow
dad
part
healthy women women always go back to
what's normal to them yeah everybody can
like a little bit of drama but a healthy
woman such as yourself if a man keeps on
cheating on her calling you out your
name you ain't staying there but a girl
came from a broken background a broken
household where that's normal that is
home for her women always go back home
so to your point yes some women do like
a very toxic unhealthy drama but I would
argue women like yourself who come from
healthy backgrounds is only so much
drama they can take before they're going
to lead this individual yeah you know I
think you're right I just think like
this isn't this is very honest and it
probably makes me look bad but like I
think on some level women like drama
like in general so in general so I'm
gonna give you one of my theories I've
been working on free game to the people
explains why women like drama usually
wear drama yeah I call this high value
man insecurity I hate using the word
high value man things a terrible word
it's been wasted all I just can't say
it's not our dad I'm I'm gonna use it
for the sake of this conversation high
value man insecurity there is a natural
drama that a woman has when she's around
a very successful man give it a case in
point let's say you meet your husband
tall handsome successful doing well in
life you and your husband go into a a
room right let's say you're at a Gallop
he's handsome you know that he's
handsome all of a sudden you see all
these women looking at your husband you
walk in the room something in you as a
woman just starts getting a little
jealous a little territory it feels kind
of way holding on to him a little bit
more yeah back off [ __ ] exactly back
off then all of a sudden right he has
he's a successful man he has to go meet
the People Meet the donors meet the
people in the room he has to go and talk
to people yeah your husband goes he's
talking to people talking to this guy
talking to this guy but he's not rude
he's not sexist he has talked to the
women as well he starts talking to the
women all of a sudden that same girl is
giving you dirty looks he's he's a man
he didn't notice it but you noticed it
yeah she's now talking to him and she's
laughing and giggling and flirting he's
just being kind begin the drama episode
two of season 17 of pearly's marriage
now this bi is now trying to take my man
yeah Begins the drama now you're mad at
now you're mad at her but you also mad
at him why are you talking to him why is
that in the third dad for just talking
um trust me because you because you're
gonna be upset because like you should
see that she's flirting with you oh okay
you're like you're I'm like yeah come on
come on stop playing this game you know
how it is why are you every five minutes
a lot of games I play so so what ends up
happening is that that gives you a
little bit of insecurity that insecurity
makes you feel kind of way you start
playing scenarios in your brain that
creates the drama so there's things that
are natural these are natural behaviors
that when you're with a very successful
very attractive man you will feel and
those men whether they're good or bad or
in between they make women feel that way
and that behavior makes you at times
cling closer to that guy because if
every other girl in the room wants them
you definitely don't want other girls to
beat you yeah they call it um I forgot
the term is but it's like it's like when
girls prefer the guys that like the
girls want yeah yeah so that's an
example of like crazy drama you're not
do you not understand though um because
back to something where
we were there like you you men get a bad
deal today when it comes to marriage a
hundred percent men get bad deals when
it comes to marriage but who is signing
those deals you see I'm a solution
oriented person yeah I no I know I just
want to I just of course so you do agree
with me that okay do men get bad deals
okay but here's the reality yeah do all
men get bad deals let's let's explain
you so one of the conversations that
people have is about the prenup yeah
you're in UK you know this
and and correctly correct me if I'm
wrong because I don't notice all the top
of my head so I'm I don't know this
study yeah maybe you've noticed better
than I do I saw a study where it said
women from 20 to 29 in UK are starting
to out earn men have you seen that study
before yeah I've heard of I've heard
I've heard that in major I actually
didn't hear about that one but I heard
it a major cities in the major cities
yeah so right so Matt Google women are
out guys yeah I love it so think about
that so there are some men right now who
are dating women who out earned them
it's safe to say yes so if that guy gets
married to that woman and they get
divorced they don't sign a prenup who
gets most who's winning that deal the
person with less money so for some guys
it is a good deal well but men only win
13 of alimony cases no I didn't say
alimony okay alimony is a totally
different thing because that's a rare
occasion because think about it to get
like you want to go down there I mean
but like even if we if we did
um like like the way it would be split
up do you really think men are gonna get
the bad or the women are going to get
the bad if you're dating a doctor I knew
a guy right now dating a doctor is
making 410 000 a year this guy is an
audio engineer making about fifty
thousand dollars a year so when they
split their assets in the divorce case
as I've seen in other situations and
this one woman actually called me in for
a session describing what happened the
man is going to get more than what he
then what he came in with that's why
they tell heiresses to sign contracts
they tell heiresses to always that
contract to prenups because they said yo
our family got all this money we don't
want that man coming in and taking it so
in some cases yes I'm not saying it's
most I'm not saying it's all in some
cases yes and so therefore there are
some situations where women um men are
getting better deals if you are a guy
and most girls and you can't get sex
consistently and all of a sudden you
find a girl and you convince a girl to
want to be with you even though she's
not really happy and you're getting sex
occasionally you are getting the better
deal because in the free market you
couldn't get sex
um consistently so for some guys the sex
that they're getting they could not get
that in the free market and so one of
mine
listen
every man is not the kind of guy who's
like I'm gonna pay a hooker every single
twice at once a week once every other
week I understand that but I'm just like
gosh you're gonna you're gonna marry her
and sign that contracts every now and
how many men are signing how many men
are signing getting married because
they're having sex what do we talk about
that's the world we're living in all of
them I'm just thinking like that's a
horrible deal of course and that's a
horrible thing now what did I tell you
the men are signing those bad deals yeah
so to me here's my here's my rule of
thumb with Mary this is why like I said
I'm a little bit nuanced yeah I view
successful marriage as successful
businessmen you have a successful
YouTube channel but you know the
analytics more than everybody else how
many percent of YouTube channels have 10
000 subscribers how many have a hundred
thousand subscribers how many have 500
000 subscribers you can look it up right
now on social Blaze analytics and you
can be able to see that you are part of
the 0.1 of one percent of content
creators you are at the top of the
mountain but guess what happens what is
your third tier on patreon that you're
doing third tier of your all of his
YouTube membership for patreon
serious social media social media and
what and what are you helping them with
oh that's the first tier I know
tiers when you said you're helping them
with social media isn't it no it's like
you connect on social media okay the
fourth tier is one-on-one coaching yeah
yeah so why are people calling you
because they want to get to where you're
at yeah they want to get to the point
one percent of the point one percent
point one percent do you tell them hey
the reality is 99 of people will never
get here so stop wasting your time no
you're saying you know even if most
people are not gonna get here I'm gonna
help you get there so for me there are
people who are who are married right now
I'm not sure if your parents are still
married or not yeah they are shout out
to your beautiful chairs they have 10
kids too beautiful yeah I love it all
yeah yeah there are people like your
parents and my parents who've been who
are living happy healthy marriages right
my biggest thing is I want to create
more of that I know it's the exception
not the rule I want to create more of
that the same way there's a limited
amount of millionaires but we still want
to all aspire to be millionaires yeah I
want to Aspire for the best yeah no and
I I agree with you but like I just I
just really understand the guys when
they they want to walk away because I
just when I walk into ways for quitters
but when I hear these law at least
legally at least legally because when I
hear these laws I'm like this is crazy
you can protect yourself from these
things it's the year 2000 see here's my
problem I listen being black in America
you don't get victimhood excuses you
don't get things whine and complain you
see the biggest problem especially with
a lot of these red pill mantle Spirit
manosphere kind of guys is they get to
play the victim all day all day long
being being black in America there's no
excuses I don't care the laws I don't
care what the police says I don't care
who's racist I don't care make it work
make it work so women like you in all
due respect you guys oh my gosh the poor
guys and they have so it's so hard for
them man that's life that is life let me
finish that is life for a man it is
extremely difficult it is extremely
challenging bad things happen to you and
you have to learn how to overcome it it
is the year 2022. I understand in the
year 1992 when bad things were happening
that you had nothing to do with it now
there is so many tools resources online
to be able to protect yourself and
prevent these things from happening
those old school messages are not
relevant in 2022 in the information era
I'm I'm not saying like poor men I'm
saying like I I feel like the laws
should change so I understand the
mindset of we are walking away until the
laws change it's kind of like a protest
sure and you don't understand that sure
like let's be honest let's stop playing
this game what kind of men are walking
away what kind of men are walking away
is it really the men that women want
they're really attractive handsome
successful men that are walking away or
is that really what's going on or is it
or is it a 23 year old virgin who can't
have any sex you say I'm walking away
from women they walked away from you
first so my biggest thing with some of
this protesting is who's protesting
because it's so funny because what
happens is you have all these guys on
internet saying I don't do relationships
and I know them in person and they have
girlfriends they have wives on the side
they don't tell people these things no
one's walking away but the foolish kids
who are watching this content online
those guys not walking we ain't even
living without women they don't have a
relationship you don't have any kids
walking away from no games no games not
you yeah
I know I'm saying like we're walking
away from marriage and you can see that
and you can see that because the
marriage rates are lower than lower 50
of women that hit 30 or single and
childless so so I I would who's walking
away are the billionaires walking away
from Marriage are there are the are the
heiresses walking away from Marriage the
first person that comes into my head is
Leonardo DiCaprio that man is not
married what about George Clooney
George Clooney come on we we can go
maybe I'm not a big movie person I just
think George Clooney is a big starter
glutenant he's not he's the Leonardo's
what is he in top something no that's
Tom Cruise I'm really I'm not trying to
be disingenuous I'm just really not a
movie my point is show me who's walking
away stop playing these games women
don't care about those guys who are
walking away go go they're freaking red
pill Randy 7x253 they don't care about
him walking away the average come on man
yeah those guys are they will get
married the rock is married yeah LeBron
James is married yeah Jay-Z is married
stop playing these games they don't care
about those guys you're not protesting
you think you're it's like that fat girl
who's like we're having a sex protest
the 300 pound book beluga whales are
having a sex protest and all of a sudden
the men are going to behave themselves
yeah right no one cares about you
protesting it's interesting I know I've
just met a lot of guys through the show
that have said like that they want and I
know you'll say maybe they're capping I
don't know but they don't want to get
married at least legally and I
understand that like if you wouldn't
want to get married legally let me tell
you about those guys there was a time in
the day where there's a bunch of
feminists they were in their early 20s
and they would say we're we're not
having any kids the world's
overpopulated oh marriage is this we're
not having any children this day you
think they're the exact equivalent 100
exact equivalent and all of a sudden 35
years old you knock on that girl's door
hey Susie oh what's back there oh a face
those are my kids one two three three
kids yeah what happened to that feminist
stuff when the world's overpopulated I
mean I was 20 years old I feel you know
it was just you know I was in college
my hair was blue it was just a phase
yeah see me in 10 years see my my my
play is 10 years right now people don't
realize I'm stopping putting out content
I'm actually slowing everything down
intentionally because in 10 years it's
gonna be time and 10 years what's gonna
happen is we will see who is right and
who is wrong we will see how many of
these people who are saying I'm never
gonna get married we're gonna see
because right now we're in the era of
where everybody can say whatever they
want to say but then all of a sudden the
same way there was a time of the day
where the pickup artist Community what
the most prevalent community in today's
society and all of a sudden years later
it fell apart because it was not good
for the Long Haul so my biggest thing is
that that is let's play the 10-year game
and in 10 years we will see if I'm a
faker if I'm a liar if I'm deceitful you
will see it actually and I deserve to be
exposed and hung from the highest cross
but my biggest thing that we will see
and we will be able to figure out that
the guys who are lying who are capping
and they will see and what breaks my
heart is that it's gonna be a whole
community of guys who are going to
follow these men to enter the Earth and
they're going to change their ways at
the end of the race and all of a sudden
the guys will be like what happened the
same way shout out to my girl sham booty
shambui said one of my biggest
regressors when I was in my 20s I told
women that I didn't want any kids I
don't want any kids I don't want any
kids and all of a sudden now I'm 35 I
have a bunch of kids I'm the happiest
person on planet Earth and it hurts me
because there were some women who took
my advice now that they're never going
to have any kids because they're now 45
and not like me who can be able to have
kids older or older in life so my
biggest thing is that when we're giving
people real life advice and real life
information we will see in 10 years how
much you live this life how much is this
for the content how much is this if
you're is this about what you genuinely
believe we will see in 10 years so what
what percent of red pill content
creators do you think actually live the
life that they say
to your point the challenge is
entertainment and the best comedy is
that office type comedy where you don't
know what's serious and what's not so to
me if if I was to look at their content
I would say maybe two three percent of
them two three percent if that live live
because to me I know it as a guy you can
be like man I tell women this and I tell
women that and I tell but deep man you
ain't doing that back home stop playing
it's just it's just talk but then it
might be a young guy who's like oh yeah
I'm gonna do it like that it's just talk
can I have an example huh I personally
uh-huh will not talk about anybody if
they are not in the room I will not no
you don't you can just be abroad you
don't have to say their name or anything
I just wanted I meant like an example of
a situation like that so here's the deal
like I said a lot of people tell me
stuff in private that I'm not gonna ever
shout out publicly but I'm Gonna Give
You examples there's guys who will tell
you I don't do relationships I don't do
it years later then you'll have a whole
girlfriend I don't do family then years
later they're married so to me you like
I said it's a this next tendency I I
it's I've been watching male content for
so long and I've seen how this stuff
goes and you just seeing how it plays
I've seen the cycle yeah I seen the
dudes that come on the scene and say
this and so Jordan I'm this and I'm that
and then use weight wait wait guys wait
let's see how his life really turns out
you know oh my gosh another one this is
another cycle to me and it breaks my
heart because if what I love that you
said is this entertainment keep it 100
It's Entertainment and you are also
trying to help but it's primarily for
entertainment so don't act like you
really believe all these ideas
everything that you're communicating to
these men stop acting like you genuinely
believe all these things because you
don't and let's keep it 100 I would
never be if the red pill simply said is
all of our opinions a lot of his jokes
is we're not really serious about most
of this stuff some of it we are some of
it we believe but most of it is just a
little funny I would have no problems
whatsoever but when you say we are the
truth come on man don't don't let's not
let's not do this don't let's not
deceive these men I won't be see these
Men Please Don't deceive these men these
are real life human beings and their
real lives lives and their children's
life and their grandchildren's lives
that are at stake like you said it's a
serious problem going on in today's
world let's not play around with these
men it is a matter of life and death in
the tongue do not play with these men
and their lives and their legacies I
refuse to do that so what are solutions
to you then so I love your question
solution number one
is we need to build up stronger more
competent powerful men who are assertive
who have boundaries who are respectful
who are financially stable who are
physically fit who are emotionally
healthy who are spiritually grounded we
need well-rounded men who not only have
all the skills that make women happy but
also have all the skills to make a woman
horny we need those men not just these
you know these nice guy Weenie Hut
Juniors who are doormats
actually I've never I didn't know that
was from SpongeBob it was it was and we
don't also need these hyper masculine
bravado gaston-like characters we don't
need either or we need strong competent
capable men and we need to create
um places where those men where men can
come and get those resources that's why
I'm so passionate about the standard the
reality of the standards when men join
the standard they're around my life I
can't fake nothing I told the guys this
in December when I started I said yo if
I'm faking what I'm saying if I don't
live what I preach you guys will be
around shout out to J.R Garcia and the
Andres and the lions and all the guys in
the standard they know it they know it
they're around me all the time I I can't
am I faking it I told you if I'm fake
they can expose me in a minute because
they're around me so my biggest thing is
that we need to go and create
communities where we're building up men
we're teaching them how to have healthy
marriages because marriage some
marriages do work do a lot a lot of them
unhappy yes but some are happy let's
learn from them let's replicate them
let's learn from your parents let's
learn from my parents let's learn from
the people who are doing well and let's
teach the men how to do those things
let's also protect them and protect them
in if you're a guy here you have lots of
money let's protect them that's if your
guy you're worried about your children
losing custody let's protect them let's
teach strategies and techniques to
protect men as well as women because to
me the best advice benefits men and
benefits women I want you protected as
well I don't want you to be 45 years old
and all of a sudden your husband says
screw you I'm about to get a new woman
now all of a sudden you're 45 with three
three kids and now you're like I want to
go back in the mating market after I hit
the the wall I don't want to go back
into the mini market that's not fair we
have to protect you as well so I want to
protect the men protect the women and on
top of that or we're building up
stronger men we got to build up healthy
women because my biggest pushback why I
don't like the showing the hoes on um
your show the the currency of today's is
is attention that is a currency if you
ask the 18 year old kid which would
rather have a million followers and a
million followers and a thousand dollars
or a um a thousand followers and a
million dollars well thousand in a
minute you ask the average 18 year old
kid today no I'm thinking like you'd
have to make the the money higher for it
to be comparable a million dollars yeah
and a thousand followers or a million
followers and a thousand sorry oh yeah
that I picked a million dollars 18 year
old kids know what the currency of today
is followers yeah they want the cloud
they want that blue check they want that
followers on Tick Tock you don't give a
thing about the money because they'll be
like you know I'll use my followers to
get the money they think to follow
attention today is the currency so my a
lot of these women who are doing this
foolishness you know why they're doing
it because there's attention there if
there was no attention they wouldn't do
it if these girls if they if they
twerked on Instagram and they got two
followers and they got three likes
They're Gonna Stop Twerking real goddamn
quick and so my biggest thing is that we
need to stop incentivizing their
behavior we need to stop celebrating
these women's unhealthy Behavior we need
to stop showing them we need to freaking
give them no attention you see what
happens is and and it's like La La Land
to me that'll never happen well and
guess what no not also is La La Land the
world that you're describing as well
because we because you asked somebody 70
years ago could the world ever get this
bad they said it would never get this
way it would never get this bad this
will never happen but guess what
sometimes La La Land exists and good and
in bad so the same way same way Society
can can go down unless you're saying
screw it and screw it I think in the 70s
they would have believed it what you
mean the free love [ __ ] they would have
believed it man that was some hippies in
California those are some hippies in
Woodstock they didn't think that would
go into New York City and Alabama in
Iowa in South Dakota and all in Arkansas
I didn't believe it was gonna go all
around the world like the way it is
going right now my point is duh we need
to stop it the people with wisdom need
to stop incentivizing those women I
never forget and I keep on going back to
it women women know I can go I can go in
your charm school I can act a fool and
guess what my only fans will go up
because I will get more followers the
more rude I go rude I am on your show on
wife Academy I'm the nasty B word imma
get more followers I'm gonna get more
guys subscribed to my only fans so their
incentivized to go on your show and
active fool screw that you are not
getting a dollar a penny a cent from me
I will give you zero zero brand
awareness I will give you zero publicity
because we're not celebrating women like
you we are celebrating the positive
women the healthy women the women who
want to create lasting families women
who actually want to stay through thin
and thin through Thin and Thick we want
to celebrate women like that that's the
solution emphasizing highlighting those
women and all those women all the
Instagram followers why do they have
millions of followers why are men
following those women you're calling
them three or fours why are you
following them why are you on their page
why are you liking them if you if men
simply said screw it i'm we're done with
the Instagram we're done with the only
things we're done with the tick tock
make it shut this whole thing down they
make their money from men men are the
leaders in society so to me we either
played a victim mindset and woe with me
the world's coming to an end and screw
it I'm just gonna go hide and travel the
world and bang random unhealthy women or
we can say you know what Society is
going to hell in the hand basket but not
during my lifetime during my lifetime
while I'm here I'm gonna do every
freaking thing in my power to stop this
fools from going down even if things are
not creating a lasting change it will
this the ship will not go down on my
watch it's just interesting you have all
this like men should be more but like I
I didn't really hear much that the women
need to do what did I tell you at the
very you weren't even listening what did
I tell you you said we need to it I said
women such as yourself have the most
power you know why because you have the
ability to create healthier women women
you're a woman they will be able to
listen to you once you get the
credibility once you get your tone once
you get your approach I can't create
wife Academy that idea had years ago I
couldn't create it I must a man telling
women how to be a wife no they're not
gonna listen why not like Kevin Samuels
did let me tell you something it's like
his audience was like 40 women which is
really mad in the nanosphere let me tell
you something and look up school of
affluence when you get the chance she is
what I she does a little bit differently
but she has like a 90 female audience
but she's a little bit different she's
not she doesn't have the values that you
and I may have but she's teaching women
how to be the women that the kind of man
that she goes after wants and she has a
huge audience for it so my biggest thing
is God rested the dead nothing but great
things I will always say publicly
nothing but great things about the
Godfather himself Kevin Samuels my
biggest thing is I don't want 40. I want
you to get 80 90 of women I want you to
be and women like yourself to be able to
help a next generation of women and we
are doing it with a standard a lot of
women come to our events a lot of really
healthy women are being tapped into the
community could have seen while those
guys are over there those guys are being
successful because what happens is like
you said the women want the attention
from the men if the men are like we
don't want only fans no we don't want
PornHub no we don't want that no some of
the women will get in line well most of
them get in line it doesn't matter we
want someone to get in line and then we
then you factor that into the equation
women's such as yourself and other
common creators like you who are now
creating a healthier better generation
of women not worried about those three
or fours and just simply trying to make
mindless content but actually taking the
women who want to learn give them the
tools to be successful that truly to me
will create the change in society but I
just think like 40 of I mean I think we
just see it in a different way like I
think 40 of like Millions is better than
90 of a thousand and a big pull up your
phone right now type in anime so
um this phone you could do it on your
phone because this phone died this is my
UK phone so like it actually doesn't
this phone died I'm gonna pull up Anna
bass YouTube channel
okay okay let's let's put Annabelle's
YouTube channel would you say it she had
the same poll like Kevin Samuels Andrew
Tate any of them okay how many family
followers does she have uh 1.39 million
go to our videos and see her videos as
well uh-huh go ahead dude
I'm looking my point is that the win is
I wonder if you think she'd do wife
School wait ah trust me she's doing wife
School her way that's what I'm telling
you she's doing but she's
you have to pay a lot of money she's
yeah we
we trust me I know how much money you
make she
doing well so okay trust me I understand
people tell me a lot of things I I know
I've been around the block I meet a lot
of different people I know you're doing
well my plan the reason why I brought up
Anna Bay is because she's doing very
very very high-end things and she's and
obviously she's she's in Europe as well
which might work a little bit better for
you I think she's in Sweden by the way
and so my point with her is that she
actually has a community of women she's
able to talk directly to women and to be
able to influence and change women's
lives and so to me that is what it's
about we need women doing this I cannot
argue that she has the same reach as
someone like Kevin Samuels and that's
what I'm saying like like 40 of a
million is better than than you know 90
of a thousand and I don't like I know
she's got 1.4 but I'm saying like Kevin
was bigger like everyone knew who he was
here's here's a reality similar to you
and I yeah you we are both forgetting
two fundamental things like I said I
don't wanna I don't like talking about
individual people Kevin is not here the
only reason I'm just using it as an
example like that's the only reason
here's what I'm saying shout out to
Kevin Samuels Kevin Samuels he would do
a lot of things in person he had to stop
because of um of covet but my biggest
thing is that the the reach is great God
bless the reach but what's really most
impactful which which what takes the
most time is to invest your time and
energy into actually being with the
individuals like events you're talking
about yeah events meetups it takes that
takes time you can't record seven days a
week if you're doing meetups and doing
the best of traveling around the world
actually because we're trying to set the
yeah I know I know so to me it goes back
to what maximum maximum exposure or
Maximum Impact there's a balancing act
and the and the more you want to have an
impact the less of exposure you're going
to have because impact happens right
here face to face one-on-one person to
person you can't only do so much of that
and so my biggest thing is the Maximum
Impact I believe women's yourself can do
is actually one being the things that
you're telling women that they need to
be to start off with yourself so if
you're like you know what women should
get married they should be this Saturday
you need to be that needs to be probably
number one on your list and then once
you're able to just do that yourself
you'll be able to then help other women
get there as well that to me is a change
because my desire is that a 17 year old
woman can say you know what I can either
be that Instagram model have millions of
subscribers have millions of dollars but
no husband no children living a
depressed life or it can be just pearly
things have a beautiful husband have a
beautiful children have a beautiful life
also have the millions of dollars and
subscribers and do it the right way when
we're able to show a society that there
is an alternative because what's
happening today's world is that the
alternative is not more sexual than the
other thing I want to lift up the
alternative that's why I'm so passionate
about creating lasting and real change
in this world and women like you like I
said previously I can't do it you guys
got to do it what do you think of
divorce do you think there is ever an
instance when someone should get
divorced 100 000 of course that's why
God put it in the Old Testament in the
New Testament of course you're a better
Christian than me like I don't I don't
actually know that yeah what are the
reasons adultery okay adultery because
you left the Covenant okay so here's how
it works in Christian theology okay you
have a covenant with one another you
make an agreement
if one person chose to leave the
Covenant therefore it's already over
they've already divorced so therefore if
the agreement in the Covenant is you and
I are only going to be the our only two
partners you've stepped out of the
Covenant and went and and became one
with somebody else you've already left
me
I'm not divorcing you you've divorced
the divorce is situation where when
that's where there's a place and there's
a lot of more Nuance because in New
Testament theology it's also something
called the hardness of the heart and
that's when the other person has done
some done things that are so depraved
and they're not even trying to make this
marriage work a case of one example for
like a woman if you're if a woman has an
abusive husband that's beating her up
every single day should we tell her to
go back to her husband you know what I
mean that's foolishness right or a man
your man has a woman who's always trying
to stab him with knives and attack them
in this house should we tell them to go
back to that woman of course not so
obviously this is a case-by-case basin
there's a lot of nuance in between what
do you think about
um when men are in sexless marriages do
you think they should leave here's a
reality because one in four marriages
are sexless and that's a problem okay so
my biggest thing going back to so here's
reality my dad always said prevention is
better than the cure to cure a problem
is huge prevent it it's like right right
so I'm all about prevention right I'm
all about preventing this from happening
if you and your wife get married and
you're a guy you're trying to get
married because like we have a lot of
practical tangible advice advice about
getting married it's not it's not being
naive and being like Oh everything's
happily ever after it's not being
nihilistic it's gonna end a divorce no
matter what it's realism practical
advice here's a practical advice about
getting married
you and your wife need to sit down and
talk about what is expected and what
happens if you don't do the right thing
now I know I'm going around the block
but I want I'm gonna get there right
yeah
if you you want children yeah how many
children do you want I always say as
many as I can let's say you want five
kids yeah I was about to say four or
five yeah you want five kids you meet a
guy and you say hey you know what I
really want kids do you want kids he
said yes yeah you get married you want
kids yeah your two marriage you want
kids yeah year five in marriage you want
kids yeah hold on one second seven years
we haven't had any kids do you want kids
I don't want any kids anymore should you
say married to that man no no I would I
would yeah cause what happened he
promised you one thing children yeah he
promised you something that's very
meaningful to you yeah and he tricked
you you only agreed to that Covenant
because there was rules the rule was
we're gonna have kids that's why I
signed this deal then all of a sudden
you changed up on me and now you're
saying no kids ever and I'm gonna be a
barren woman and die alone no that's
wrong so of course he's broken the
Covenant he's broken the promise to you
same way with the sexism so if you are a
guy and you're we're agreeing oh
marriage we're going to be having sex
consist
at least twice a week at least once a
week that's what we're doing that's what
we agreed upon that's part of our
agreement now you're in year five and
she doesn't want to have sex anymore she
changed her mind she's not in the mood
now one month two months three more four
months five months a year into it no sex
hey baby I want to have sex hey baby I
want to have sex I want to have sex with
me let's do it no no no no no no you I
signed this deal because you promised me
sex now all of a sudden you switch up on
me you've you've broken the terms of
disagreement you've left this Covenant
we you've left not me you've tricked me
you've deceived me so man no it's
unhealthy but if she gets fat going back
I feel this way yeah yeah if I if you
agreed to stay in shape I got a lot of
flack for that one no you agree to stay
in shape you can leave the whales you
hear it from puppies listen I'm not
saying leave the whales
now we call them entitled whales oh Lord
Jesus if I to me that is not fair if my
if my woman met me with a six-pack abs
ripped muscles looking good she's always
turned on by me and all of a sudden
years later I'm a fat disgusting blob
looking like Jabba the Hutt from Star
Wars looking like like one of those
things from Wally and then all of a
sudden she's not turned on I mean she
said hey baby can you get back in shape
I say no hey baby can you lose some
weight I say no why that's not fair for
her I agreed for one thing she's doing
something else so if you're a woman
promise you made an agreement to use one
thing he was a medical emergency and
it's a season of her life but if she's
like I am 300 pounds though I will not
lose a single pound screw you you got to
deal with it that is not what I signed
up for and as a manager needs to be
repercussions going back to marital
agreement there needs to be Reaper
because I'm not saying divorce I never
said once you purchase a divorce and for
either situation but I'm saying their
needs to to be a repercussion for
tricking somebody into that contract is
that
size from these like
and they're like so like
like this baby's so sad stories
like I'm saying like you don't feel bad
like okay because there are some guys
that are honestly in like bad situations
where they they married they married a
girl and they think like one thing and
then she gains a bunch away it won't
have sex with him and if they leave like
they're putting the kids at a big
disadvantage and like it's kind of like
and and if they leave you know she can
take half that's why they have the term
it's cheaper to keep her and and it's
like I and you can and you could say
it's like the world's smallest violin or
what like whatever you're gonna you're
gonna say boohoo but like I think that's
a hard reality for men listen
the first five years I did nothing but
played a violin I did nothing but here
story after Story of pain of suffering
of difficulties of hardships I have
heard it I have cried the tears publicly
on my Channel about the men who are
suffering in today's society I have
experienced and have seen some of my
friends experience the worst kinds of
divorces things that are so beyond
demonic it will blow your mind if I
talked about it on this platform I have
seen the worst of the worst but guess
what
we've spent years talking about the
worst of the worst we've been spent
years talking about the problems in
today's world now it is time for
Solutions do I have compassion but what
does compassion do for the next man
who's up now it's time for Solutions yes
life hits you yes you're knocked down
yes you have a crappy hand now what and
so my biggest thing is that like I said
be when you're being an individual who's
black in America you learn it's hard
people have crappy hands people go
through difficulty man so many bad
things happen in today's world it's hard
it's tough it's painful people right now
literally watching this video are crying
tears of suffering because they're
living in absolute hell I understand the
pain of men more than anybody because
I've been doing this for so long but
what I'm saying is we cannot simply stay
there it's okay not to be okay what are
our Solutions what is the the way
forward and simply just plain the violin
simply regurgitating and re-uttering the
same points about men suffering over and
over again does not change the next man
from suffering does not change the
situation I want Solutions that's what I
live and bleed I want Solutions I want
men to be better that is what I'm about
I'm not simply disregarding that was all
entertainment we're having fun here you
wanted views you're the one who told me
you gotta make an entertainment for
people to watch now you're mad I'm
entertaining all right all of a sudden
I'm not mad we're having fun
come on I'm just talking I understand
but I cannot leave men there because the
victim mindset because think about if
you've been victimized what are you done
so a hundred percent men have been
victimized but I cannot let a man embody
the victim mindset you got a bad hand in
life I will refuse I will never let a
single man no matter how difficult he
has it embody the victim mindset have
you ever tried to like do you want to
run for an office or anything would you
ever try to change the laws at all or is
that is that not something here's here's
the deal if I was to run for office I
guarantee you if I really put all my
effort into it we will see a lot of laws
change because that's what makes me so
mad because I I have my path my I have
my certain path I know for a fact God
God did not make me to be a politician
that's not what I'm made to be my path
is to build up the men my path is to
give them everything that needs to be
great my path is one-on-ones connected
that's that's my past standard type
stuff that's what I'm and so to me the
reason why I'm so mad at some of the red
pill guys I'm like yo why won't you guys
get into politics your path is not mine
yeah you feel like they're just making
money off of you
get into it get in the game if if there
was a guy who's like I spent because
there's a lot of guys in the MRI
Community right who are trying to make a
change I love those guys because they're
everything they're they're in Capitol
Hill they're fighting for the divorce
lawyers they're fighting for the the the
custody laws they're fighting I love
those freaking guys all power to those
guys and those guys need to be uplifted
and share this story and people need to
be sending them money because they're
trying to make a change so I don't
altered amazing lawyers who are trying
to make it Equitable for men in divorce
situation let's shout them out I love
those guys those are my guys and so but
to me I can't be everything I can't be
the politician and then the king maker
and this and that and there I can't be
all these things I need some help but
when I see all the other guys who are
way smarter than me who have way more
wisdom than I do have way more tools
than I do when I see all those guys
simply spend all their day long on the
internet regurgitating the same boring
top talking points talking about the
same problems that we already know
exists I'm like how are you this old and
still doing this you're old now get into
make real change but to me I just wonder
why if like no I understand that I
understand so it's like it's frustrating
to you because uh now I understand
though not even the passion I mean this
because we feel this feel this I mean
look at me in my eyes because you just
feel like you've been listening to this
content for like 10 plus years and so
it's like for you it's been like 10 15
years of the same stuff same but there's
never there's never any actual change
that's that's what you feel and and to
me I feel as though same with you and
your women's your wife your wife school
you should be able to graduate
you should get to a point where you
don't got to watch pearly things anymore
because you have your husband you are a
wife if and my problem is these guys
have repeat customers every single day
for multiple years how was the same guy
watching your content how the same guy
going through that same BS how the same
guys like come on this should come a
time in a day where people should
graduate from you if they shouldn't need
it anymore sometimes I don't think they
want to graduate there's some people a
hundred you know why no why I don't know
did a victim yeah yeah you're right yeah
yeah think about it no because I went to
I went to a funny thing I did I went to
a pickup artist conference oh God I just
I just was curious I want to know what
the guys were talking about so it's kind
of like if you as a guy went to like uh
how to finesse like Rich guys cop it'd
be kind of interesting you know so I
went for like a YouTube video and some
some of them did not want to be helped
of course yeah I was like because
everything was just everyone else and
not some of them genuinely were there to
learn and like I was like okay that's
kind of interesting those are the ones I
love yeah so when I'm always when I'm
always going at the red pill stuff I'm
not trying to pick a fight with any
individual Creator which is why I want
to do reaction videos with me what I
never I never talk about them I never
respond because they don't exist to me
what I'm obsessive is that that guy you
described that small percentage of guy
who's at that conference who's watching
that content who really wants help that
guy I care about that guy I just want to
reach that one guy and I want to give
him all the tools to be successful and
so to me you're 100 right there's some
people who do not want to be helped they
want to complain they want to why they
want to see you destroy women they want
to see everybody else destroy women but
they don't want to change they don't
want to get in shape they don't want to
improve their lives they don't want a
level they don't want this stuff they
want to sit down on their couches they
want to turn on the YouTube and they
want to Simply complain vent and type in
Nast things in the comments about women
and that is the stuff that disgusts me
and that's why I'm so passionate about
what we're doing because we're creating
real change in this in the world in the
lives of men
okay yeah I think I understand the
you're very passionate about this stuff
and and I love how you because you're
feeling it remember this you said you're
very tired I said don't worry we'll get
there we'll get there I like you're very
tired of me I'm still tired now but this
is my life yeah like that's why people
don't realize it's my life no I
understand this is what I live so from
your point like from your point of view
you've just been listening to this stuff
for too long without Solutions and
that's like that's like where you're at
is like you just for years have been
hearing the same talking points and then
because to me this stuff is like more
new so I don't really my question is
what year did you what year did you
start watching this content year and a
half ago maybe 2020 because you found me
in 2020. so you obviously no you but
I'll listen to more of your yours wasn't
like red red pill like I listened to
your interviews before then I've been
listening to you guys I think for longer
but okay like red pill I would Define as
like more AMS role like it's kind of red
pill Pua with the stuff out very
interesting
um but that I would say like like two
years one year my question is has it
changed in the past two years the
content yeah
um I would say the person that was like
that chain like I think Kevin Samuels
did the best job of like moving forward
the conversation I think it's a really a
shame that he died because I actually
thought that he he did the best job of
like moving the conversation 100 I love
what Andrew Tate too I think is changing
a lot yeah like he's he's very different
um like the first video I actually
didn't like Andrew Tate when I started
because he he had like a cheating party
and I was like that's a bit rude yeah
but then like it's like interesting to
see his content like evolve and think
about what you just said Yeah you
mentioned two people who I have nothing
but the utmost respect yeah people who
started off their stuff was wild yeah
Kevin but I've been watching Kevin for a
long time boy Kevin Used to Be Wild
Andrew Tate Used to Be Wild yeah but
they've grown they've improved they've
made their messes better they refine it
they've lost a lot of dollars if Kevin
Simmons wanted to maximize money he
would simply keep on doing the same
thing because it was Jerry Springer kept
on working yeah but he was like no I I
will lose the dollars I will lose the
fame I will lose all the things to be
better same with Andrew Tate so I read
nothing but respect for those you never
hear me say anything bad publicly about
those two individuals but what pisses me
off is those other guys who are doing
the same things year after year after
year after year I'm like you're too old
for this I get it when it's a new 22
year old kid who pops up on YouTube and
starts uttering the same fools it's like
yeah he's 22. he doesn't know any better
but you're in your 50s you're in your
your this old come on man that's
ridiculous and to me that's worth like
you're either naive and you don't know
what's going on which I don't believe
these people are that dumb or you're
intentionally you're intentionally
deceiving these men and leading them
them down on unhealthy path especially
when you're not even living that life
and that's what pisses me off and so
you're saying like a lot of those guys
behind the scenes they're still they
have relationships wives girlfriends but
they're just still spewing the same
stuff and that's where your frustration
with the red pill like comes in I know
some and like I said I'm not calling
anybody yeah I know a lot of people
personally I know people I think almost
anybody right now I want to talk to my
phone I can't everyone tells me these
stories I know this that's why I'm so
passionate about it I know these things
and so my biggest thing is that yo stop
like if you don't lie to people man stop
lying that's what bothers me the most
like bro like don't lie to them because
kids are actually following this and
somebody my dad told me this and I want
you if you remember anything that I told
you remember this what you do in
moderation those who follow you will do
an excess remember that whatever you do
in moderation those who follow you will
do an excess so be careful what you do
in front of people so you have to be
aware of it if I feel like oh I'm
leading people down this wrong path you
have to adjust because they will take
what you're doing and they'll multiply
it so to me that's one of the biggest
things that I've learned if you're not
improving if you're not adjusting you
are you are simply leading people down
an unhealthy path because if there is no
growth that means that the death is
occurring well tell the people where
they can find you listen man but they
but you're not going to put out content
I mean you're putting out less content
here's a reality I don't want follows no
but don't follow follow her if you
subscribe to her Channel follow her on
Instagram like I don't I don't want
followers I don't want likes I don't
want do your thing if you want to find
go on roommates content on the roommates
I don't I don't want any of this stuff
I want people to be healthy so my advice
is I am not the truth I am not the
prophet I am a man who likes to read
books and share my opinion my advice to
every man and woman out there is find an
older person who has the life that you
want to have the family that you want to
have the job that you want to have the
respect that you want to have find
somebody don't worry don't find don't
don't don't follow me find the older
more and more successful established
person and copy their life learn from
them don't learn from me I'm a 32 year
old kid who just likes to read books and
share my opinions I'm trying to figure
things out don't follow me find older
seasoned intelligent individuals who are
where you want to be learn from them
follow them and follow their path and
make sure that that they're living the
life that they're actually communicating
so that you don't go to go don't excuse
me so that you don't go down go down the
wrong path and that's what I'm extremely
passionate about okay well thank you for
coming um of course guys don't forget to
like the video on your way out and
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and we'll talk to you
next time